good morning everybody there we go uh
we're waiting for one more of the
committee members we'll give them
another couple minutes and then we'll
get started
good morning everybody
representative turcotte i'll be chairing
this subcommittee work session on uh
hb 1210 it's actually a culmination of
hp 1210 1351 and 1358
we'll speak a little bit more of that
once we get into it
first like to have the clerk take the
rule call please
representative turcotte here
avalani
huff i'm here
uh representative sullivan
and representative bouchard
representative avalani
we'll assume that's a here
we're just taking the role
okay um
as i said this uh we had three bills
that were all related to uh
vaccines in the workplace
13 58
12 10
and 13 51
so what we did is the subcommittee was
formed and
i had the three prime sponsors of the
bills
pretty much get together
with a few of us occasionally
and
attempt to come up with an amendment
that would encompass
what we thought or what the
sponsors thought were
taking the good out of them and
releasing some of the bad in them so
what came out of that was
amendment 2022-0724-h
representative lang i'm going to have
him speak to it he uh did the majority
of the work on it so
representative lang
thank you mr chairman representative um
so on on this amendment we did we took
those three bills we found segments of
the bills that we thought all thought
were worked well um the first of which
is the the general findings section i'm
just making a statement a fact about the
general what what we believe as a
general court
um in speaking with both ols you know as
we were this is like the fifth draft of
this amendment um as we were working
with everybody and speaking a less we
felt it was important to separate out
the business aspect from the educational
aspect and put the business and labor
law and the labor law statutes and put
the educational laws
into educational statutes rather than do
it as one
simple
one bill that encompasses both in in a
single paragraph so you'll see
um
we we brought out in uh in 275 78
we we talk about the exemption vaccine
mandates public and private employers
um we change this to do um to talk about
only businesses that take federal
federal estate funds is the first thing
we set a qualifier so it doesn't apply
to all businesses that if you have a
private business 100 private doesn't
have any governmental interaction other
than paying taxes then they would would
not be subject to this law if they take
federal money or take state money in any
way shape or form then they would be
subject to this this new new rule
um and the rule does the same thing as
we talked about before it creates uh the
law creates a simple form allowing the
uh
employee or two or student in the second
half of the bill to um choose that they
they fall within one of three categories
and then on the employer side we made a
significant change where before we had
we talked about reasonable
accommodations and that's a standard
practice in business that they do even
currently now
we said that originally in the original
amendment we talked about the word will
where it says the employer on line 22 of
the first page the employer it now says
may then work with an employee and we
had will originally kind of like a
forced mandate on the business and we
chose not to do that we chose to
back that off and change it to may so if
there's a way for the employer to work
with the uh employee we want to see them
do that if possible
there may be certain terms and circumst
or certain circumstances where that's
not possible um and so we left that
provision to the to the business
um
we created a separability clause so if
anything in this uh section three of the
of the bill page one um that if any
portion of this law is uh deemed
unconstitutional um then only that
segment of the law is strict not the
entire law
um and then we do the same thing we go
into the education statutes and we have
the same exact terms and conditions
again if it's a if it's a school that
takes federal or state money um and then
we have the same process for the student
submitting a request for an exemption in
the post-secondary education
um
i think this is a ex you know we again i
worked with the prime sponsors i i
worked with several members um i thought
this was a reasonable um amendment to
kind of consolidate everything down you
know it's a real delicate balancing act
trying to
protect the business right to do
business and protect a citizen's right
to be a citizen and not be imposed upon
unreasonably and so i think this bill
does that
balances those two to rights so to speak
um and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you representative lang do we have
any questions from the
committee
representative sullivan
thank you um
representative blang i you pointed out
the um
uh
statement in line 22 the employer may
then work with the employee to see if an
agreement for reasonable accommodation
can be reached
two questions
what do you envision as being a
reasonable accommodation in this
situation
um and two if the accommodation cannot
be reached what happens
sure thank you for your question and and
what i'll say is that this is current
business practice already so they do
this already um prior to coving the
politization of covid and and everything
businesses routinely dealt with
exemption requests um so i'll give you
examples i'm subject to him to a vaccine
mandate
i chose i didn't want to give my data to
my business so i told them that i said
i'm not telling you my vaccines it's
none of your business i said but i'm
willing to accept accommodation and you
can treat me as if i'm unvaccinated
regardless of what my status is and my
business chose to ask me to test
whenever i go into the office if i'm
gonna be around other fellow employees
or i'm gonna be backstage because i
happen to work in a concert field and i
felt that was a reasonable accommodation
i said i'll accept that because my
infection status is more important than
my vaccine status so in this case i
chose to accept that accommodation i
felt it was reasonable they have they
have a significant business interest
that i recognize and i felt that my
my accepting the testing was a
reasonable response so
there may be other circumstances and
again i'll go back to what i said in the
public hearing on this bill you know we
use uh in nursing right which is where
this this most often comes up
in a cancer ward
right i think it may be and i'm not
saying it is because i don't know all
the case law behind it but it may be
reasonable for a hospital say there are
no accommodations that you can make that
would that could reduce the risk
significantly enough to protect our
cancer patients so therefore if you
refuse to get uh
vaccinated then we're gonna move you
into a different ward you cannot work in
oncology that may be a reasonable i
don't know if it is again but i could
understand why a hospital may want to
make that statement and be allowed and
then it's up for them to defend that if
the employee says that's unreasonable
and they can file a wrongful termination
suit um but again i think that that's
again current law this is currently
what's happening already um i mean when
i say current law it's current practice
in businesses we're just putting it into
law to make sure that is clear
follow-up
so
i think what i heard you say wrongful
terminations so i believe that implies
that if the employer and the employee
cannot agree on an accommodation then
the employee would likely be terminated
the employer has the right to terminate
uh where the employee is the right to
quit either one
thank you
any other questions from the
representative bouchard
um
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question
i'm i'm pretty clear about what a
medical exemption is
a religious exemption is
could you
define to me what the right of
conscience exemption is
my most favorite question i get asked
right now most recently
um so the right of conscience is a um is
a moral objection so i'm going to give
you an example and it's it's a little
it's not off topic so to speak but i
found it when i was researching uh bills
on it like this
is that doctors enjoy the right of
conscience when it comes to abortion
a doctor can refuse to perform a
procedure and is protected by federal
law if they declare a right of
conscience that they find it morally
objectionable to perform an abortion and
they cannot be discriminated against if
they do that
so there's an example of a moral belief
that someone may have
that gives them the right not to do
something
so i don't think it's any more
you know if we're going to join and give
doctors that right of conscience and say
that they can choose more what is
morally repugnant to them
and and and don't want to do it and not
be discriminated against we should be
able to give our citizens that same
exact right
follower
how could you
relate a right of conscience
to a
for a vaccination
how do i relate to two yeah sure so if i
think it's it's morally wrong to inject
myself
with a chemical right i i believe it
hurts my body in some way shape or form
and that's my moral belief then why
should i be forced to do that
if i you know
there's a body of evidence you know
around that there are implications of
vaccinations to people
they may be minimal it may be small it
may be infidesimal but if a person
honestly believes that it they've made
the decision not to inject those kind of
chemicals into their body and usually it
can be from birth you know i know
families that none of their kids have
ever been vaccinated because the parents
believe that it's not a good thing
um that's their moral belief are we
going to judge them on their moral
belief for that and tell them that
they're not entitled to their moral
beliefs
thank you
could you guys turn off your mics
representative avaloni
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative lang just a question on
the grant portion in paragraph 1 line 13
to 18.
um
we have
last year year before we had the main
street grants
sent out by the state to
businesses that were affected by the
covet 19 shutdown
does that make them public employers
if they receive those grants
i'm sorry if i heard your question right
if they received
any covet funds would they be considered
a public employer is that your question
correct
i'm going to say yes
any other questions from the committee
representative selma
just a follow-up to what uh
representative avalani was just saying
um so a restaurant that receives um
uh coveted funds as well would be um
covered by this bill correct
that would be my interpretation yes
any business that received federal funds
a business that chose not to receive
federal funds would not be subject to
this bill
i have uh one question representative
link
back to the uh conscientious uh
question that was was asked the right of
conscience
would it be fair to say that that
we talked about it's a moral issue would
we would it be fair to say that the
right of conscience is similar to the
religious exception without
the tag of religion
thank you mr chair and i'd say that's
exactly correct i would say probably the
majority of the people that currently
are fall underneath the right of
conscience are using the religious
exemptions anyway so i don't think it's
a necessarily significant number that
we're talking about that would
differentiate
thank you are there any other questions
for representative lange
um
representative solem again
the
the other difference um when you look at
the religious exemption and the medical
exemption
in adding the conscientious objection
the other difference however is that all
they have to do is say i object
and there's no further questions no
further justification no further
explanation is that correct
if the law if this amendment is adopted
on all three circumstances again this
comes back to the question of whether or
not you think it's appropriate for
businesses to ask for medical data even
though they're not asking for
um
they're not asking for necessarily an
accommodation they're not saying i want
you to change my work habits because i
have this medical condition it's not a
reflective phrase i'm saying a true ada
requirement on religion it's even easier
is do we really want our businesses or
um
uh you having to say tell them what what
religion you are what tenant of your
faith is and then have them check to see
whether or not you're religious enough
to be entitled to the exemption so in
all of these i don't think we should be
checking we self-attest to more things
in our society
on almost everything when you go into
motor vehicle you give them a driver's
license you give them a birth
certificate and some other form of id
social security card neither one of
which has your picture on it and you
sign a form saying this is who i am
right we we regularly self attest with
some basic information
and in society when you register your
kid for school i actually don't have to
show a driver's license to register my
kid to prove who i am so we regularly
believe and take on faith within the
government our citizens answers to
things and i don't think this should be
any different
follow-up
however at present it is different and
an employer is entitled to ask
for backup information about the medical
or the religious exemption correct
that is correct and and again one of the
reasons this bill came forward is is and
i i spoke about this i think my original
testimony was on 9 12 of 2001
um the attorney the the surgeon general
of the united states said that he was
going to start checking into employers
employees whether or not they were
abusing the religious exemption
and if that doesn't take a bone-chilling
effect about the fact that
a a senior member of our government is
saying we're going to start measuring
our citizen spirituality
i don't know what is government has no
business in my religion
any other questions
you can
you have a question
as a member of the committee
you can i've never done this so i'm just
making sure
somebody else told uh
i caution you mr chairman
mr chairman my uh
my opinion of a subcommittee is usually
what you're doing now the subcommittee
has their debate they discuss it okay um
questions are asked of the subcommittee
of the sponsor uh the subcommittee can
then ask questions of any particular
person out there whether it be a
lobbyist or the department you know and
then that would be my
my assumption only i was told something
differently by the uh
our administrator this goalie said
something different but that's fine go
ahead
he's chairman of the subcommittee can
act representative
i have two questions one of which i just
want to follow the bouncing ball here
regarding something you said
um
because i want to make sure you use the
right term you mentioned a situation
where
someone chooses to be any of these three
reasons they want to not
take the vaccine
they tell their employer the employer
will endeavor to
provide some kind of accommodation if
accommodation cannot be made
you then said i believe you said then
they could file suit
i believe
the the procedure it is now and the
procedure you're continuing to go with
is if they cannot get
a um
an accommodation they can either quit
they can
contest
to the department of labor
the department of labor then
investigates looking at whether the
accommodations that were offered are
consistent
with
past practice
if they are
consistent with past practice then it
would be fine no no problem if not then
the department of labor could then step
in and say no that's inconsistent
with past practice
and then
whatever
either force the employer to be more
consistent or then find against the
employer is that your understanding of
the way it is that is my understanding
follow-up please mr chairman
the only thing that concerns me that's
not been brought up thus far
is all these fear-mongering emails and
calls i've received in the last three
days
that
because this does not fit some
federal guideline
hundreds of millions of dollars from
nursing homes whether it be the county
nursing homes private nursing homes
hospitals associated with getting
medicare and medicaid
this will
interfere with that and negate that and
they will no longer be able to receive
those monies
thank you for the question i can tell
you that this is a similar concern that
was brought up in in florida when they
they amended their their exemption
statutes and to date cms has done
nothing
the government is not acting on this
they recognize that exemptions um are
allowed um probably the biggest concern
in this bill is the fact that we've
added the right of conscience compared
to other than that this bill would
conform with all of the cms rules um the
the right of consciences though in new
hampshire has been extremely like like i
said in my testimonies called out
various explicitly is unalienable that
our citizens have the right um and i'll
be honest with you they'll be happy to
remove uh
the uh right of conscience uh in this
bill if someone could tell me how i can
unvaccinate myself
any other questions from the committee
representative lang i'm going to make
kind of a comment and
speaking to the importance of the
in line 22 the may versus will
i mean i can give you a
much like yourself um i've been directly
affected by this the whole vaccine
mandate
situation
i can certainly see
examples of where may
is much more beneficial than will only
because there may actually be some
businesses out there
that want to be able to point to this
and go write a conscience right of
conscience i'm going to give you the
exact example myself okay
initially last fall
pilots at american airlines and all of
the major airlines
fell under the
mandate that president biden put down on
federal contractors okay
we received
an email from our chief pilot saying you
have such and such amount of time to get
vaccinated otherwise you're going to be
terminated for myself after 37 years of
service
long story short our company did not in
the least want to eliminate
20 of their workforce uh pilots you're
not going to be able to run an airline
when you you know get rid of 2500 pilots
out of 14 000.
so this to me when i look at this this
would be american airlines management
going
now we don't have to fire our pilots we
don't
we don't want to require them to get the
vaccine the feds are telling us this but
here we get the right of conscience and
i'm just using my airline as an example
this could apply to you know
you know different businesses but would
you see that as a fair point
i do an extremely fair point again i i
look to use one of the governor's
favorite words flex right this allows
business to flex and manage their
business so they choose to manage it
we're not putting uh in that ability to
work or to choose to work if they need
to but they also may say there's no
accommodation necessary we don't need to
do anything you're fine
and so this allows for that in either
direction you can either choose to let's
work with it work with you and find an
accommodation or after reviewing in your
thing based if you're a home-based
employee there's no accommodation
necessary so just continue working at
home we don't need you to do anything so
again i think that this is a flexibility
bill it allows the flexibility for
businesses to be able to operate um and
i think it's uh again it's a great
balancing act between the rights of the
citizens and the rights of the
businesses thank you
any other questions from committee
members
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
um
and this is just
just for clarification for myself
it says on line 17 shall offer
the employee the opportunity to submit
it doesn't say
shall accept
so
what i'm what i'm driving at here is
is that this says that they will have to
have the um
employee know that they can uh
give an exemption request
and the exemption request would come in
and it says
that they may
decide to work with an agreement but
there aren't the the employer is under
no obligation
at all to
so i'd have you take a look at line 21
under section two where it says such
requests for exemption shall be granted
okay
and then we go into the main i withdraw
my request my question thank you
representative lang would you be willing
to take questions from anybody out there
if they have them absolutely mr chairman
and i don't know uh
deputy commissioner ogden would you like
to say come up to the mic make some
comments and then we'll open if anybody
else in the
gallery has questions we'll open to them
thank you representative turcotte um and
thank you representative lang in terms
of questions the only thing i would
provide is just some general uh
commentary specific to some of what
we've heard today i would just want to
point out relative to representative
avalani's question about receiving
funding
absent additional clarification we the
department would look at
lines 13 and 14 where it says any public
or private employer that receives public
funds we would look at it as something
of an ongoing that there is a receipt of
public funds if the intent is to say
that had they ever received public funds
they would fall under this umbrella i
think perhaps that should be clarified
representative infantine had made the
comment about reasonable accommodation
or reviewing the reasonableness of
accommodations i do want to be clear
that the new hampshire department of
labor does not typically engage in that
type of analysis specifically when we're
talking about reasonable accommodations
most often i think most folks understand
it coming up in the context of
ada requests or things of that nature
that's all under federal purview so i
just want to be clear that that type of
analysis does not typically fall with us
saying that in practice i believe how
the department of labor in new hampshire
would interpret and apply this law would
be mainly that we see that there is now
a requirement
that if someone files one of these forms
it shall be granted it done does say
that the parties can work together we
would be looking to say okay it's
reasonable if the parties have agreed to
that because again the text of the uh
provided legislation says that uh the
employer may then work with the employee
to see if an agreement for a reasonable
accommodation can be reached essentially
i will tell you in practice i think what
we would do is we would say did the
parties come to an agreement if they
came to an agreement that works if they
didn't come to an agreement
uh and it led to termination
we would then probably look at that and
say okay
the exemption was then not fully or
granted in some form and i don't i don't
know if we're misinterpreting
what you're trying to do here we would
look at this as saying employers
requiring this exemption shall be
granted meaning they should not require
it they can then try to work to some
type of accommodation
if they work to the accommodation and
agree to it fine if they don't
and then the person was terminated and
someone then complained to us we would
likely look and say okay
exemption not granted
employer you should grant that exemption
they would get 30 days because sitting
in 275 this would be under our general
penalty powers so there'd be 30 days for
the employer to correct it and namely
correction i imagine would be saying
you should have granted the exemption in
both you know form and you know actually
do it
if they don't do it then
after the warning period expires the 30
days we would be able to impose a
penalty of up to 2 500 dollars um i see
it as more of a deterrence factor than
anything is we would say you're supposed
to do this if you don't do this you
should be penalized the only other thing
i would point out is this does not
clearly give us job restoration
authority um you know when it was talked
about wrongful terminations and things
of that nature that's not something that
comes to us or or is administered by us
so i just want to be clear that the
department's application of this law
would most likely be in the form of
deterrence saying you should be granting
this if you're not granting this you
could be penalized so i'm happy to take
questions and as you guys know it's not
us putting forth policy or in any way
trying to advise what should be done i
just want to be clear that's how we
would interpret or apply this
and i want to be very clear on that
reasonable accommodation that's not
analysis we do so we would be looking
did the parties come to an agreement or
not
so i'm happy to take any questions thank
you anybody on committee representative
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner ogden
line 13 was
an issue
and i'm glad you brought it up would you
make a recommendation
of a change that would clarify
an ongoing use of public funds for daily
operations or a one-time
or a segmented or relief fund or
something like that how would you
differentiate between the two
so that a
one-time grant to a
place of business that they don't become
automatically become a public employer
again i think there should perhaps be
clarity in terms of if you're looking
for one-time recipients to uh fall under
this i think you would want it to say
something akin to receives or has ever
received if you want it to be an ongoing
thing
it should probably be clarified to say
something to the effect of regularly
receives or receives uh on a
schedule basis or something of that
nature i apologize i don't have the
words immediately at mine but i would
just suggest that you do perhaps look to
clarify that depending upon what the
intent is i don't know what the uh clear
intent is there if it's ever or ongoing
thank you mr chairman thank you debbie
commissioner
um
one question on that
the ongoing versus uh one time other
than can can you think of any
instances other than
recently with the covid
pandemic can
are there any other instances you can
think of where there have been one time
mass influxes of
capital to businesses
um not off the top of my head but one i
mean
looking at the language here where it
talks about federal contracts i guess
one way to look if they ever
had done a federal contract or had ever
touched it but i'm not um i think covid
is unique in the sense of i think all of
a sudden there were a lot of businesses
um receiving an influx but i can't
think of many other examples so
so the issue there is maybe
okay thank you any other questions
no
thank you rep
commissioner deputy commissioner ogden
are there any questions
from
the gallery for representative lange
come on up
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record paula minnihan
senior vice president state government
relations for the new hampshire hospital
association
we
testified in opposition to the original
bill and we remain opposed to this bill
and i will outline for you why
how important
our medicaid and medicare funding is and
that in fact it would be in jeopardy if
this bill were to pass it is in direct
violation of the cms requirements i am
happy to share with you some documents
from cms
but
i know it was cha it's been challenged
and questioned um not in only in this
committee but other committees um
relative to
um whether or not
federal funding would be in violation
and i
am happy to share with you but um
it's um one
faq which i think is very um informative
and i'm happy to share it with you how
will this new requirement which is the
vaccine requirement be enforced then
they talk about state surveys which are
you know it's a very pro it's a
very significant process that state
surveyors um in our case it's under
health facilities that they would be
surveying the um for compliance of
nursing homes not only private but also
county nursing homes as well as new
hampshire hospital and all hospitals and
anyone that's actually any facility that
falls under health facilities
how do the penalties work
medicare and medicaid certified
facilities are expected to comply with
all regulatory requirements and cms has
a variety of established enforcement
remedies for nursing homes
home health agencies hospice
this would include civil monetary
penalties denial of payment and even
termination from the medicare and
medicaid program as a final measure the
remedy for non-compliance among
hospitals and certain other acute and
continuing care providers is termination
however cms goal is to bring health care
facilities into compliance termination
would generally occur only after
providing a facility with the
opportunity to make corrections and come
into compliance that answers the
question about florida i've heard that
numerous times in numerous committees
florida has a law that is in
direct
conflict with cms federal requirements
and the reason probably nothing has
happened it's either the facilities are
already um following the cms
requirements and um or
they um they're just cms has not gone
into those facilities in florida but i
would contend that that is not something
that new hampshire wants to actually
challenge because that would put our
hospitals um in direct conflict and then
you're you have this this issue with
what the other is the other question
that continually comes up is well new
hampshire law would would supersede
federal law according to cms the the
answer is quite different what happens
if state law prohibits vaccine mandates
how does how can cms expect a facility
to follow its requirements if the state
prevails
prevents them excuse me from
implementing this rule under the
supremacy clause of the u.s constitution
this regulation preempts any state law
to the contrary so that is directly from
cms in addition conscientious objection
and i will direct you to a letter and i
know david juve from the bia is here so
i'm not going to speak for him but he
wrote a very compelling letter to on
dated february 10th to this committee
relative to conscientious objection and
why it is not um
it should not be included relative to
this vaccine or
yeah vaccine exemptions the hospitals
and i obviously represent hospitals so
hospitals have routinely and have for a
long time allowed for medical and
religious exemptions the right of
conscience is not contemplated never has
been and continues not to be and cms
does not allow for that conscientious
objection as the bia letter indicates is
is um is not contemplated um so that
that's another cms um violation the
other part where um you allow for a
simple
submit a request which is um as
representative lang said very simple the
pot the hospitals must have policies
relative to medical and religious
exemptions have forever um they've
allowed they've required flu vaccines
and other vaccines as i've i think my
testimony in prior um hearings have
stated
they have a policy they have a very con
very
significant process that they go through
for reviewing every medical and
religious exemption
so again um that
that
line 20 um
just submitting a request and stating
that you have a conscientious objection
effectively
nullifies the entire vaccine
requirement because again that is not
you raise your hand and you say i object
um that that is not contemplated by cms
so so the hospitals cannot
cannot meet that requirement um the
shall again you cannot have a review and
and actually
render a fair and reasonable um review
and and process for the employee you
just shall be it shall be granted and
then the accommodations um i um i i've
heard this is stated for that it's
current business practice but um i would
um not i would contend that you can't
just re um
reallocate resources if you will if a
nurse if an icu nurse is on is unwilling
to follow this and and indicates they
want an accommodation
there are very
important considerations relative to
patients and their vulnerabilities i
don't care if they're if you are an icu
patient or if you're a podiatry patient
if you have
underlying health conditions you are at
risk and and our hospitals have contend
that that is not a risk that they are
willing to take so they that is why they
have put in this policy
um
i think
i mean it's restated again as
representative lang said under the
education relative to
students
and i know there are others in the
audience that actually teach nursing
students so perhaps it would be best to
have them speak to this but
it is our understanding that the um the
nursing programs they have really not
had a problem relative to ensuring that
um those that go into a hospital for a
rotation are um following the the
requirements of that institution and
again everyone that's in a volunt then
again it's cms requirement volunteers
contractors employees unless you're 100
remote must follow the cms mandate and
when you have a student come in for a
rotation in a hospital
they are rotating throughout every
department including labor and delivery
so again unwilling the hospitals are
unwilling and will not put those
patients and and certainly those
unvaccinated
newborns in in harm's way um i think
that's it for my comments happy to
answer any questions
thank you anybody have any questions
representative sullivan
this bill does not specifically address
covid uh it more generally uh addresses
vaccines you're right can you
tell us how big a problem it would be if
someone refused to take any vaccinations
whatsoever
that is a very um astute point and
you're right it's any vaccine um so
again
currently um hospitals um and i probably
have it in my testimony there's a whole
list of um vaccinations inoculations
that are required i don't think it's in
this testimony but it was in another
testimony um so um
there's and again there's a nurse
sitting in the audience she knows pam um
dinopoly i think can can cite those but
there are a whole list of vaccinations
that are required as a condition of
employment pre-covered and continues to
be you're right those are also would be
in jeopardy um
if this were to pass
thank you for your question
representative lang thank you if i can
ask questions i'm looking at this bill
and we we're looking at potential you
know using this as a basis and maybe
mending so having inputs important
um
so i guess my question is my intent to
this
of this bill with the exception of the
new ad of right of conscience um
was to put into law basically current
procedures my understanding currently
that hospitals do allow for both medical
and religious exemptions and they do if
there is a possibility of
of accommodations uh grant
accommodations is that not accurate
um
that's that is accurate the
conscientious objection is the problem
that's the only only problem you have in
here is the right of conscience that
issue of adding the right of conscience
is that
so
that is again one violation that would
be in direct
contradiction with cms so the right of
conscience is definitely an issue um the
um
the written request shall shall simply
state like i said the policy is is
otherwise um there is a form and there's
a process that there's a policy and a
process so that is makes it a little
less
and again this is also cms in indicates
this and then it says
such requests for exemption shall
it doesn't say may it says shall again
if you follow this
each word that indicates that you it
doesn't matter what
is
what the process is that you it shall be
granted if you put it if you sign a
piece of paper it shall be granted
that's the way i read it maybe that's
not your intent but that's the way i
read it so if i can follow up something
i'm trying to figure out how i might
reword this to make it more palatable
for people
um
so again
the
if anything what this law would do is
simplify the process rather than
complicate the process in that
you would not have to investigate
medical
exemption requests you wouldn't have to
investigate religious you don't find out
what person what a person's religion is
what tenant of their faith is it that
requires them not to get the vaccine you
don't have to look at past practices of
the patient of the worker so this would
simplify that process dramatically for
the business would it not
i think it would actually make it more
challenging because um
you're again
what's the point if there is no due
process the employer owes that employee
due process if you just say i want a
medical re exemption and that shall be
granted that ex that exemption there is
no process so that's the problem i
understand what your concerns are but
again cms requirements actually do
require that you document it because
again the surveyors remember the
surveyors the hospitals are
under
cms survey
and they have to be ready at all times
so health facilities comes in and this
is a survey requirement they say what is
your policy
you have to give it to them and show me
what the process has been have you
treated employees fairly have you given
them that due process and if you did
what is outlined in this i appreciate
that it would be simpler it just
wouldn't be in viola it would not be
surveyable if that's even a word you
could not the surveyor could not
check the box and say you met the cms
requirements you're now in jeopardy your
conditions of participation in medicare
and medicaid could be are in jeopardy
they could cite you and then again the
process as i outlined would start this
is this is
i i
i know i heard representative infantine
say fear-mongering it's not it is this
is serious
sam
60 to 80 percent of hospitals
reimbursement is medicare and medicaid
60-80 80
they would be
in they would lose their cm their
federal and state funding this i am not
this is not fear-mongering i i promise
you it's not this is this is serious and
that's why the the
administration went to the supreme court
and asked for a ruling so that it could
be clear i also hear from other
legislators that don't think that it
that is the
the final word but it is it's the
supreme court and no one is no other
lower court is
going into appealing that it is
cms mandate is
is being implemented it's just it's just
being implemented now that's why we're
not hearing from
i think i think the first state is
probably florida um but we we should not
i i
we should not put those our hospitals in
that kind of jeopardy we should not
all yours
thank you mr chairman
um
question for you about i think we heard
from
uh mr lavers in the unemployment section
a little while ago this committee did
about health care workers where their
exception was granted
but their employer made the
determination that no accommodation was
possible given the nature of their work
do you see this bill changing that
uh in any way that that that that
balancing could still be made where you
acknowledge their exemption as and
granted but still have to make the
determination of whether an
accommodation is possible under the
circumstances of their employment
i
i'm not sure that i i'm remembering the
same testimony from
mr lavers but i
believe
employment security was talking about
those that were not granted an
exemption and went to employment
security looking for unemployment
benefits and his statistics indicated
that the i can't remember i i have it
written down somewhere that out of 90 um
you know
80 were upheld or whatever i i i
shouldn't even state the stats but i
that was my understanding is they were
challenged they wanted unemployment
benefits because they
they they left employment
because their exemption was not granted
i'm not um but i apologize i don't i
don't i think i'm might be remembering a
different um testimony i'm not sure
representative
um thank you actually it was the inverse
of that i think it was something like
90 were denied and i think you're
talking about that 90 was denied i think
that but the 10 percent that were
granted i believe were employers that
acknowledged
and accepted either their medical or
religious exemption as valid
but then found through the circumstances
their employment
there was no possible way to accommodate
them in this situation and that was the
minority that was their unemployment was
granted and paid oh okay thank you thank
you that's that's the group i was asking
about okay and whether this would change
any existing practice because i think it
would put
it would short circuit the first step
with the exception and the the exemption
would be acknowledged as granted but i
don't think that the intent of this bill
is to short circus that secondary
investigation of whether an
accommodation is possible given the
circumstances of the work and i was
wondering whether you saw it differently
than what i just said or not i guess
i would
question if
if this is current law why do we need
this because if the the employer may
then work with the employee to see if an
agreement for a reasonable accommodation
can be reached
and like you said i think that's what
they try to do
if um the um exemption is granted and um
and
and then they try to accommodate or yeah
yeah so that like you said that minority
piece probably a good idea to have mr
lavers come back and talk about that um
but again if they're they're already
making accommodations so i'm not sure
why we would need that stated in law i
guess
thank you
uh representative bouchard
thank you for answering of course
when you read this bill
do you interpret it
that
anybody can walk in an employee
to the employer and say
i do not want to be vaccinated
and
it's because of
religion
or medical
or conscientious and then you have to
grant it
yes
yes representative bouchard that's how i
interpret it it is an automatic um
because of the shall be granted um and
this is of course when
if they require a vaccination
requirement and
yes
okay so just a follow-up please
how is that different from
what's happening now
so
the hospitals have a
requirement
they impose the requirements starting in
august
long before
the federal government
came down with their cms
requirement
so they determined that based on the
safety of patients and their employees
and because of the nature of the work
that they do that they needed to impose
these vaccination requirements for covid
before that again there's a whole litany
of other require employee employment
related vaccinations that hospitals have
imposed for years
you know flu vaccine is is the most
common but there are a whole bunch of
them mmr and a whole bunch of um
i think well again um there's a list i
have it written and i'm happy to share
it with you
um so
they
require it and if someone were to say i
cannot get the flu vaccine i because i'm
allergic to
what's in the flu vaccine for instance
um and my so they would they would
request a medical
exemption
and there's a policy a written policy
and then you fill out a form and then it
goes to a committee um with clinicians
at the hospital and they review that
um and it's a signed document from the
patient from the patient's physician or
provider stating why they cannot have
the flu vaccine
then the then that's reviewed and if
it's accommodated then um
if it's agreed sorry if it's accepted
then the accommodation may be full ppe
um you know prior to to covet we weren't
all wearing masks but the hospitals um
during flu flu season they certainly do
um but they might have to wear um
additional protection because of the um
you know how how highly contagious the
flu virus is
so um that's what would happen they
would make an accommodation like that so
during flu season
you must wear a mask if you or other ppe
if you are not
able to get the flu vaccine did i answer
your question thank you okay you're
welcome
thank you
i have a series of questions for you
sure
the last one you just uh the comment you
made
i think actually plays to what uh
representative lang's trying to do here
you just said that reasonable
accommodation is made for the flu on an
annual basis by
requiring the individual to wear a mask
or some other thing i mean uh
unfortunately it some of my other
comments go to
covert versus everything else we've ever
dealt with and
you're the reason we're seeing a lot of
this stuff is because of that
um first question
well let's start from the back forward
you mentioned um when we were talking
about the conscientious objection versus
religious
i'm going to give you example
representative huff here we work for the
same company
it doesn't matter what it is
he submits a religious
he submits a religious exemption
and i submit a relig uh
an
conscientious objector or whatever the
wording is in here
because i can't truthfully
put forward a religious exemption
what is the difference
net outcome
between
when he is granted his exemption and i'm
not in your
bus not in in the nursing or hospital or
that but in general what's in that
effect is there any difference in the
outcome of
representative huff and myself
mike
so the policy
right now
again i can't speak for other employers
but for hospitals they allow for medical
and religious exemptions so you go
through the process and then
representative huff's um religious
exemption
would be considered by the committee and
either granted or not granted and then
that's communicated let's get way beyond
that
we've already gotten through all of this
he's got the he's got his exemption
is there any difference in
how
either one of us are going to be handled
the conscientious objection is not a is
not on the list i understand that i'm
saying under this bill if it passes what
is going to be the difference
between how he is handled and i'm
handled the hospital would be in direct
um
violation of
i'm not
i'm trying to get it away from the
hospital scene because this but i
represent hospitals so so maybe it'd be
better for david somebody else okay uh
let's go back to the very beginning you
were reading some faqs from cms what
date were those put out they were put
out they were updated hold on i and
again i'm happy to send this
they were new
some of them were were new in um
january 20th
2022.
they were new a couple weeks ago
the ones that you read were new on the
22nd um they were initially
issued on november 5th 2021
and have been updated as of january 20th
2022.
okay thank you
um and the title is um faq you could
actually look this up um if you wanted
and googled it um cms omnibus covid19
healthcare staff vaccination interim
final rule and it's the external faqs
and it's 15 pages long again i'm happy
to send this but i didn't want to bog
you down thank you
what
what percentage of your hospital workers
or the people you represent took the
took the job voluntarily
how many resigned because they refused
and how many what percent were actually
terminated
um i don't have those numbers right in
front of me but i would say um
well the hospitals aren't required to
report that so i we just have anecdotal
information but um some have actually
come out um dartmouth hitchcock
did a press release that they had over
uh well over 90 95
um of their employees are vaccinated or
have um received an exemption um so
i i can try and get some of that
information it's completely anecdotal
nothing is required to be submitted and
then
employment security as representative um
um
was saying um
mr represe
i think is best to answer the question
about um those that were fired and um
or were let go and then were went to
employment security and went through
that process so
i don't have those actual numbers but i
can i can see what i can get but
what has been reported by hospitals is
well over 90 95 of their employees
actually higher than 90. uh 95 plus
are either fully vaccinated or um have
met an exemption
i understand that number but that
doesn't really get to the heart of what
i'm trying to get at and that is how
many took it voluntarily and said yay i
want to take this
uh jab how many were forced to take it
under threat of losing their jobs
and
uh how many were actually terminated
because they refuse again i'll use my
company as an example we started off
with about 25 of our pilots who said i'm
not going to do it
they
president biden put in his federal
contractor mandate and under the threat
of termination
a lot of them ended up getting it our
company can now come out and say with
the same statistics you just said
95 of our company has
uh either received an exemption
or
has had the vaccine five percent of us
have done nothing didn't request we
didn't get the vaccine
so but that number at 95 percent does
not speak to how many did it only under
the threat of losing their job and i can
tell you in terms of the pilots it was
probably
i don't know 1500
1500 under the threat of their job and
we can go into anecdotals and how many
of our pilots have passed away due to
you know immediately following the the
implementation of the taking the backs
but
so
the the numbers i'm looking for is how
many people are actually saying yay i
want to take this experimental
drug where the uh it's not experimental
but um that i think we'll agree to
disagree on that but it's not
experimental
um it's fully approved by the fda
we don't have those numbers
representative um so i don't i don't
know that i'll be able to um
satisfy your your question um the vast
vast majority of healthcare workers
support the vaccination and and
willingly had that um had that
they chose to do it um they were not
um they did it well before their
employer um ever imposed um the
requirement
okay thank you any other question mr
chair
i want to restate one of your questions
i think i can get the right answer i i i
think the question the chair was trying
to get to earlier about accommodations
was if you
assuming this law went into effect and
you had to grant an exemption and create
a reasonable accommodation for those
three categories whether it's medical
religious or conscientious objector
would the accommodation be different
based on the the reason they chose the
exemption or is it
i that's a hypothetical that i can't
answer because again that's not what the
hospital's policy is now
so i don't know
again
what's more
relevant i guess i don't know if that's
the right word what's more
concerning is that they would be in
direct violation of cms that's cms
requirements so they cannot
make that accommodation without risk of
losing federal funding that's the
concern one more follow-up let's go back
to just the cms rules then so if you had
a medical exemption a religious
exemption employee and your goal is the
safety of the
patient
in the hospital
you had said that they would be required
to mask or wear full gown ppe but that
exemption would that that accommodation
wouldn't be different it's
you're giving the exemption because of
they're not taking the vaccine so
therefore the accommodation should be
the same correct
perhaps i i don't know what the
accommodation is but if you're
unvaccinated and you're treating
patients i would believe again the
hospitals have policies and they do
they they would have to
make sure again that the patients are
fully um protected um as and other staff
um so so i think what you said was that
an unvaccinated person is treated the
same as it relates to accommodations
whether regardless of the status the
reason for the reason of the
unvaccination is i i don't i don't have
specifics but i it makes it certainly
makes sense
thank you
representative sullivan did you have
anything no good
anything else from miss minihan
thank you thank you anybody else in the
audience like to talk
okay
yeah come on up and then uh
david giuve will be next and then
whoever else
can you turn on your mic please
pam dinapoli i'm a nurse and i taught at
unh for 20 years in the department of
nursing and now the executive director
of the new hampshire nurses association
and i just i understand this is a labor
committee but i think that
you have to talk about human costs and i
think the representative's comment about
this applies to all vaccines is really
an important point and the issue with
conscience objector is that it broadens
the exemption so anybody and we've seen
this over time so we've seen what
vaccines have done in terms of disease
so we have a period where
within the last 10 years there was a lot
of
disinformation about
vaccines causing autism and other things
and there were more people requesting
exemptions and at that time we saw an
increase in communicable diseases so we
know that vaccines work and we want to
limit the number of people who can claim
an exemption because as we broaden it
out
so now you don't need to have your mmr
because you don't want it for your
children so now we have a measles
outbreak in the city of manchester so
then you have to figure out who's
vaccinated who's not vaccinated so it
puts the human cost of
eliminating
a vaccine requirement is huge to
a community to the health care
profession and to to the population in
general so i just think that the problem
with this bill is broadening the
exemptions and just remember
that we're in a cove at times we're
talking as if this is just about cove
this is about human disease and we know
over time
what vaccines have done to decrease
communicable diseases so i think this is
a scary bill
from a health perspective and i think
from a labor perspective there's a lot
of cost to to human capital so i just
want you to consider that when you're
thinking about
the the
cms costs this is really human costs
that we're talking about and in terms of
post-secondary education none of our
students
cared whether or not they had to get the
vaccine they wanted their life to be
back so they line up for vaccines all of
our nursing students have had to have
vaccines to come into the program
for 20 years so you know the whole issue
that that they're going to be
that that they don't want to take it
then that impacts their clinical
experiences and that's always been the
case so you know and hospitals consider
medical and religious exemptions very
carefully so everybody gets due process
so you know i think that that you don't
want to open this up to to raise your
hand and say i don't want a vaccine it's
a it's a scary proposition
any questions
thank you
mr chair can i just make one comment
absolutely so you know we talk a lot
about the right of conscience and again
i'm going to go back to i'm literally on
the hhs.gov federal website and when it
talks about health care providers and
their right of conscience
is that specifically written right into
the law under conscience and religious
freedom
it says
con
conscience protections apply to health
care providers before who refuse to
perform accommodate or assist
uh with certain health care services on
religious or moral grounds federal
statutes protect health care providers
conscious rights to prohibit recipients
of certain federal funds from
discriminating against health care
providers or refuse to participate in
these services based on moral objections
and religious beliefs so we extend this
right of conscience to health care
providers that we have the same health
care providers refusing to extend those
same
privileges they have to our citizens and
i just find that hypocritical
thank you
mr du jouve how are you thank you
representative turcotte mr chair members
of the subcommittee for the record my
name is dave giuve i'm a senior vice
president for public policy with the
business and industry association
we serve as new hampshire statewide
chamber of commerce we have over 400
employer members with over 80 000
employees in the state i primarily just
wanted to respond to some questions that
came up that i felt
there was still some vagueness as to the
answer and i'd like to start with
representative lang you were
asking about reasonable accommodations
and whether it would differ
depending on the
exemption that was being taken if i
i'm saying that correctly my belief is
it would not differ a reasonable
accommodation
is a either a verbal or written
agreement between the employer and the
employee
for the and it relates directly to the
employee's ability to do the job so
whether they
chose a religious exemption or a medical
exemption or this new conscientious
objector exemption i don't believe that
would be a part of the discussion
between the employer and the employee
about their ability to do the job
representative turcotte you were asking
if
from a practical point of view or from
the employer point of view does it make
any difference whether
it's a medical exemption or a
conscientious objection
exemption
and i guess my response would be for
some employers
who are not actually it was
uh conscientious versus
religion okay yeah thank you for
correcting me
for some employers and i'm going to talk
about employers who are not a part of
the
the cms mandate because i do agree with
paula that those employers are under um
stricter rules than than other employers
so
most i shouldn't say most some employers
if a if a religious
or medical exemption is requested or a
new conscientious objection if this
bill is passed
they don't
take it any further they will just grant
it so in that case there would be no
difference
other employers handle it differently
and they do and there is a process an
in-house process where they will try and
evaluate
that exemption being requested the
medical exemption is fairly
straightforward um
it's not 100 fool proof but it's fairly
straightforward they check with you know
the individual's doctor and you know you
can come to a pretty quick determination
a religious exemption is a little bit
vaguer and a little bit
more difficult for an employer to engage
in a discussion on because obviously
it's a very personal
part of an individual's life
however some employers will
ask for
at least a conversation to take place
for example
what is it about your
religious that would not
allow you to feel like you could take a
vaccine and that individual would have
to respond
whatever the response is so there is
some level of discussion that takes
place
i don't see how you could have any
discussion about a conscientious
objection other than i just want to make
sure you have a conscientious objection
yes i do
check mark it off so there is a subtle
difference between
religious and conscientious objection
discussions that take place for those
employers that want to have the
discussion
and then
it seems like there might have been
another question asked but those are the
two that are at my top of mind but i'm
happy to try and answer any other
questions i i do want to
emphasize
um it i guess i should also say that
that representative lang and myself and
two
very savvy very experienced federal
labor law attorneys had a conversation
about this bill
it was cordial i thought it was very
respectful
but we did come to different conclusions
about whether the federal government
would recognize a conscientious
objection
exemption and whether the federal
government requires some documentation
on the the part of the employer
we both believe we have the
research to back up where we are at but
we differ on that
opinion
in any event i'm happy to try and answer
any questions
representative sullivan
thank you for taking my question
the um
you described under the religious and
medical
exemptions the process that employers go
through but some employers go through
would you agree that under the language
of this bill those procedures would be
eliminated because all they have to do
is sign a piece of paper saying i have a
medical objection i have
a medical i
need a medical exemption i need a
religious exemption or i need a
conscientious objection um and that's it
i i would agree with your analysis of
the bill that would render those types
of uh conversations irrelevant the
employer is required to grant the
exemption upon the request not not only
not only irrelevant but um
not allowed
well i mean from
i i suppose i would answer yes but from
an employer perspective if there's
if there's no point in having the
conversation because of what the law is
they're not going to have the
conversation
i do remember what the other issue was
mr
chair and you had asked about
companies how many
people
wouldn't want
how many how many unvaccinated employees
are there
in companies if you can sort of
suss out how many got the vaccination
because they were forced to
i only have anecdotal information on
that but it's but it's pretty good
anecdotal information at the point last
fall where the um
presidential executive order required
private sector employees of a hundred
and more to require vaccinations
we heard from
a number of our manufacturing members
that they were very concerned about this
mandate uh because they estimated they
would lose 20 to 25 percent of their
employees now that was before the
mandate was implemented so there was no
and they didn't have mandates in their
workplace so there's no reason to
believe anyone had been forced to take a
vaccination but their estimate in
and this is by the way consistent with
manufacturers who
talked to me around the state they
estimated 20 to 25 percent of their
employees would be lost
and that would go almost
uh exactly in line with my personal
situation with our pilots it was about
the about the same percentage
now i guess i should balance that and i
know this wasn't what you were asking we
had other employers
of a hundred or more who
actually implemented the vaccine mandate
before it went into effect
and so there were some employees
uh
faced that vaccination perhaps
unwillingly
and those employers reported that there
was some resistance in some grumbling
but more often than not people chose to
get the vaccine rather than lose their
job
key point let me ask you something on
let's go back to the religious uh
religious exemption versus the
conscientious
uh exemption
if there's any individual who can't
truthfully claim a religious exemption
but that can that person still be
ethical and moral
without being religious
certainly i probably fall into that
category myself as would i so
that's one of the points i was trying to
get asked before is what is the net
effect difference of a person who claims
a
uh religious exemption versus
a religion uh conscientious objection
yeah we understand the how the bill is
written i get all that
but i've yet to see
hear anybody who's opposed to this say
yeah the net effect on the individual
is the same
i guess i would suggest that
if you're going to go down that road you
could simplify this bill by just saying
uh private sector employers or
educational institutions that accept
federal and state uh
money are prohibited from implementing
vaccine mandates and just leave it at
that because the reality is
there is a difference between what is
commonly accepted as a religious
exemption where an employer has the
right to
query about that and a conscientious
objection where there's no query that
can take place
okay we're getting a little
philosophical here but again
i'm going to go back to my personal case
because that's what i know when they
came out with these the federal
contractor mandates and i was given the
choice of
get a medical
or get a religious exemption
and our company was pushing it just do
it do it do it
right
i'm healthy i couldn't claim a medical
i couldn't claim truthfully or religious
well just go put one no i'm not going to
do that
i need that other category personally
because i don't fall into that
religious or medical
so i think that's the importance of
having this category
it makes sense but it also renders any
type of
vaccine mandate
irrelevant because there is no band-aid
if a person just says i don't want to
get it that there's no mandate that
takes place
exactly
thank you anybody else just a chair yes
so just one thing into this point you're
talking about conscientious objector
versus religious and probably an
interesting statistic is
new hampshire is considered the top
non-religious state in the entire
country a lot of people consider
themselves spiritual but don't consider
themselves religious and and to a point
where you run into some problems with
the religious exemption and claiming one
i'm going to use catholicism as a great
example is that the catholic church has
come out and said
if you want to get the vaccine the
vaccines it's okay but also we recognize
that there could be some moral religious
exemptions relative to the stem cell
research that's behind it so we also
agree that if you don't want to get it
that's okay too so where does that
person fall is it really a religious
exemption when the church says yes you
can but also says no you can't how do i
how do you claim i'm not going to get it
because the church hasn't taken a
position so i don't know how this is
where conscious objector falls in or the
right of conscience falls in and says
well my church doesn't explicitly
prohibit me from getting the vaccine i
have a moral belief that i should not
get it because it's based on stem cell
research and this is why the right of
conscience
is so important yeah i would
respectfully disagree at the point
i was with you up until the point where
you said
my church or my religion has said
i can get the vaccine if i want to
however i also as a part of my religion
have strong feelings about stem cell
research and my
in my church has
made me aware of that also i would think
that would be for most employers a
legitimate religious exemption
representative
um
two questions for representative lange
if you have a moment um
do you know when the conscientious right
of conscience was added to the new
hampshire constitution
give me 30 seconds
i will say the first time it was used
conscience objector most people equate
it with law
with war and the right to the conscious
objective right now bear arms it was
actually that's not true the first time
it was used was relative of the vaccines
in england
in 1895
and it was the in in england they had a
mandatory vaccine requirement prior to
that in 1888 i think they put it in
there was so much objection that they
put another law in that granted the
right of conscience to people to not get
vaccines and that was in 1895. um to
answer your question about the right of
conscience
june 2nd 1784.
so that sounds like it was part of the
original draft
yeah june 2nd 1784. that sounds like it
was part of the original draft um
do you think that what we're talking
about the difference between a
conscientious objection a religious
exemption is
just a difference in you know the modern
way we've evolved and viewing it as
opposed to how they viewed it back then
and back then as they were trying to
talk about it conscience objection and
religious exemption
weren't as clearly delineated and were
really the same thing they were trying
to talk about is that do you think
there's a lot of overlap there or not
again i'm not a historical expert by i
do know that again based a lot of my
readings that again a lot of the
founders were deities types that
believed in some sort of spiritual being
but didn't necessarily believe in a lot
of religion you know religious you know
specific churches so to speak so i think
they were recognizing the fact that
there is a there are there's morality
and there's religiousness and that those
two things can be the same can also be
separate
thank you
mr chair if i could make one more
comment since the subject about
conscientious objections that come up in
line six
where it says the state of new hampshire
has affirmed in statute the natural
essential and inherent right to
individual bodily integrity
i am sure that's true but the state of
new hampshire has also affirmed in
statute the right of employers
to
implement health and safety regulations
in their workplace for example
you can't
well
for most places of employment
if you show up
work high as a kite from smoking
marijuana
you won't be prohibited you won't be
allowed to do your job and you may be
subject to discipline the same holds
true for drinking
uh again those
by this i think would be natural
essential or inherent rights of
individuals or to right to individual
body integrity and yet
we do have in statute the ability for
employers to impact that behavior
i would not disagree
i will make the point that legislative
findings do not end up in our statutes
anybody else for mr juve
thank you mr
my name is kate fry i'm from new futures
i'm not in front of this committee very
often um but we are a public health
organization that works on public health
policies and the health and wellness of
new hampshire residents and i'll be very
brief i just did want to underscore a
little uh what pam dinopoli said so well
is i think one of the
issues here is really understanding the
public health importance of vaccines and
i'm particularly concerned with the part
of the bill that focuses on colleges and
universities and just offering a
conscientious exemption
on all vaccines
most colleges
require
childhood vaccine and meningitis
meningical meningitis vaccines hepatitis
b
and this is really understanding the
college nature and i just sent my
last child to college and you know how
close um
kids are on campus and sharing a room
and i i can testify to that my husband
and i had to take turns in and out of
their tiny room we really have to
understand that environment to
understand the importance of these
vaccines and
it's well noted that any time you offer
conscientious or philosophical it's
usually called personal exemption
anytime you offer that the rates of
vaccinations just go down and you do
start to see the outbreak of diseases
and um
for those of you that
you know don't know but meningitis is a
very real concern on college campuses
and the outbreaks are almost always
deadly so i just think we really need to
be aware of this and when we talk about
conscientious we have to understand that
there are people who can't get vaccines
for medical reasons and no one has the
right to infect other people
and it just it really we have to keep
that in mind that these diseases are
deadly and they can be in most cases
they've been completely eradicated but
once we bring down that firewall
we will start to see increase outbreaks
thank you any questions
i just have one you mentioned meningitis
is that
and i don't know the answer is that a
required vaccine it is required at most
universities and i did just check before
it came up it is required at unh um now
it's almost always required since that
vaccine has been approved and i will say
most universities and colleges have um
also mandated the covet vaccine and i
know both my daughters were thrilled to
be able to get that vaccine and hope for
life back to normal at college
i'll follow up
uh the meningitis vaccine once that is
taken does that
prevent
that individuals from getting that
it's a it's a very foolproof vaccine i
mean there's a no vaccine is a hundred
percent but it's um made a huge
difference in outbreaks uh in colleges
and universities and i can get you more
information on that and as far as covid
is that a foolproof vaccine like
meningitis vaccine um i you know i think
we're still learning about covid and the
different it's a little bit different
because we've had so many variants
um but again going back to this bill
it's not just covet it's all vaccines so
we should be concerned about that thank
you anybody else
thank you
mr chair
if i may yes just an interesting fact
point that i think is important to this
discussion especially now that we're on
the topic of schools
was you know
when it comes to vaccinations one of the
big questions around herd immunity right
the the for public health purposes herd
immunity is important to make sure we
reach hurt immunity hurt immunities
established at a baseline of 70 that was
the number that that is generally said
that's the baseline of of where herd
immunity begins and it gets better with
as your percentage increase would
anybody care to has their guess what the
percentage of inoculations are and
vaccinations are in our public school
system
even given we allow that we allow for
exemptions
right 94 of the students have agreed to
get vaccinated the parents have agreed
to get vaccinated so we're well beyond
the hurt immunity so sometimes we talk
about this public health concern we
recognize that
we heard from mr duvet you know 80 to 95
95 percent of their employees chose to
get the vaccine so we're not talking
about a herd immunity problem here right
we're not talking about the fact that
we're not mass outbreaks nobody's ever
going to get it the reality is that new
hampshire well before covert and well
before these had a one of the top
nations for people just choosing to get
vaccine what we're recognizing here is
the individual
that has an objection for one reason
that's a small minority of our of our
population but it's still a population
that deserves protection so that's what
we're talking about thank you
is there anybody else
in the gallery who wish to speak
seeing none any other
questions comments
representative sullivan
some
comments
i don't care for this bill um i don't
intend to support this bill
um
there are limits on rights
for example we all know you can't
yell fire in the uh movie house
um that's a limit on the first amendment
rights
um
i would suggest that um
crying fire or refusing to get a
mandated
vaccination in a medical facility ought
to be an exception
i would say the same for
a college
environment
same for a county nursing home
and and same as well for state or
federal um
uh prisons
um or county
so i would suggest that
although i don't support this bill in
any form
it could be improved by carving out some
exceptions for those categories
those categories that we've received a
lot of uh
testimony about
especially the medical if we're only
going to choose one the medical one is a
critical one because of the
the medicare and medicaid aspect
i think this bill could be vastly
improved
by
making sure that um
these conditions do not apply
to medical related employment
um
so i
if the committee is interested i would
be willing to uh
try to put together a new amendment to
that effect again i probably still
wouldn't support it but it would be
better than what we have now
thank you
anybody else
representative avilani
thank you mr chairman i would just want
clarification on the public funding
that was suggested
you're talking about in uh line
one time versus ongoing and that kind of
thing yeah
okay
anybody else
okay see no more uh comments or
questions i guess what we sh
representative avalany
just a question for representative lang
if it's appropriate absolutely
representative lang could the
under the medical exemption
could that include
the right of of conscious exemption so
we don't have a third leg so we could
actually expand the definition of a
medical exemption
i'm sorry can you receive the question i
couldn't hear you
medical
given that doctors have the right of
conscience exemption could we expand the
definition of a medical exemption under
this protection
the medical exemptions are governed by
the ada by ada
as a general rule of thumb um so i'm not
sure that we could expand medical
exemptions to include the right of
conscience if that's what you're asking
that is correct we has that has that
been flushed out at all
if it could be expanded
under the medical exemption to include
right of conscience correct yeah again
right the medical exemption and maybe
someone mr duvet may have a better
answer that but my understanding is
medical the medical exemptions are
driven by
the ada law the religious exemptions are
driven by the civil rights act law
and conscience objections are driven by
our constitution
anybody else
okay so coming out of the subcommittee
[Music]
i guess we will take a
vote on recommendation uh whether or not
this amendment proceed or we recommend
it when we get back to full committee
um i know we've talked about uh
representative avalani
has talked about the
wording in line 13 i'm thinking we can
clarify that before we bring an
amendment to the
full committee if we do that
so
with that
i'll ask the
secretary to
take a vote i guess or call a roll call
vote on a recommendation to proceed
yes
yes so this will be for a recommendation
to proceed
before you do that i want to make one
comment um
we need to recognize that
there is a severability cause in this in
this bill
and i think it's fair to say that the
ultimate determination on a lot of this
stuff regarding covet is still in the
courts the supreme court has
heard arguments they've
placed a lot of their decisions back on
the federal courts so a lot of this
stuff is still yet to be settled and
it'll probably be a while before it is
and the reason we're going through a lot
of this is because i think of the
uniqueness of
covet itself and all the things that
have happened so
um
i'll call it roll
mr chair if i could
represent sullivan i would just want to
point out i hear what you're saying
about the severability i think it's good
it's in there
however with the cms questions and
concerns
no one says we have to take uh funding
from
the medicaid and medicare
so essentially it's not illegal
to uh have this this bill
it would simply cause us to forfeit all
of that funding
so
i don't think potentially
but potentially yeah but
but the risk is there and i don't think
the courts are going to say the courts
might say um yes you're going to lose
the funding but i don't think it would
say
the bill is uh unconstitutional or
violation of federal law
representative lane
thank you mr you guys want to be clear
on what you're voting on so i know what
i have to do so it sounds like we're
vote if the vote would be to recommend
otpa but the amendment may be slightly
adjusted to deal with the language
relative to
regularly versus one-time language i
don't think we can
vote the amendment ought to pass i think
we can vote to recommend it to the full
labor committee is that correct yes
thank you i i believe the form has um a
emotion on it does it not it's been a
while since i looked at it
i have never done one of these so
you can be as formal or informal as you
want you can make a recommendation
from the subcommittee
each of the members of the subcommittee
are going to have their right to discuss
their opinions of what went on in the
subcommittee
when they testify so
this is not as formal as our other votes
the goal here is to get more
detail flush out possible amendments and
possible problems to bring a better
answer to the
other representatives that were not here
better answer and possibly a better
product
it would just be helpful if we know
exactly what we're voting on okay so we
i will make the motion that we uh
support the amendment when we meet as a
full committee
for the labor committee uh with some
possible changes clarifications to the
amendment
yes
just a question as to why the
severability is in section 200.
i'm sorry can you say that he ended up
being an answer the severability is
under section 200 not 275.
so again i think the severability is in
two different locations
i'm not mistaken let me just confirm
that
yeah so it's in online 24 on page one if
any provision of this section which
deals with the labor laws and then if
you scroll down under the
um
post-secondary education there's also a
several bit of clause so there's two
different several
severability clauses in there
should they yes the follow-up yeah
should there be one under the medical
side
or dhhs side
for severability if something like this
happens
the severability would have to stick
with the chapter of law that you're
referencing it to so in this case we're
referencing uh 275 78 and that's the
chapter of that's the
and we're talking about severability of
that chapter of law or that specific rsa
so if any provision of that rsa is
deemed unconstitutional
only that provision is struck from the
law not the entire law thank you
so the motion made is there a second on
that
representative vavalani
and colorworld
i will call the roll
uh
representative avaloni
yes
uh myself yes
representative sullivan
no
representative bouchard no
representative turcotte yes
it is
three to two the motion passes
okay
so with that i will close the
subcommittee hearing on
12 hb 1210
mr chair reach out to the labor
department see if i can get help from
them on drafting what that language
would look like relative to federal and
state
monies
and i'll present that back to you okay
thank you thank you
my life
infantine
here
seaworth here
avaloni
callum
mackie myself present love
love
geez
warden
turcotte
proud
boyd
huff here
sullivan
susie
uh schultz subbing for baruti
no schultz
okay
uh cahill
fellow subbing for decelvestro here
schmidt
here
toomey yeah richard
edgerton here minimal
so
mr chair i'm sorry that i missed your
roll call but i'm representative chris
schultz i forget who i am filling in for
you
rudy well that means you have to buy the
beer so
please allow me a moment we're gonna
find out where our missing
representatives
thank you
so
he was here
representative love
is on his way um
we have a lot of bills to go through
today
i would appreciate if individuals
would try to get their
if they are making a motion or if they
are
writing the blurb
either for or against
that they try to get this
to
by monday
preferably saturday
so i don't have to read these
on vacation
but uh you guys do a great job usually
uh getting them through i think
so if you wouldn't mind i'd appreciate
getting to me as soon as you can
um also um try to keep decorum today
guys there's gonna be bills that people
want passed that aren't going to get
passed and vice versa
and um
you know we've got a lot going on here
so
uh i i'd like to um
i'm gonna if
people don't mind i'm gonna skip um some
water here
the first bill i'd like to bring it was
house bill 1076 and represent
representative adagent
thank you mr chairman uh i move ought to
pass on hb 1076 and would like to offer
amendments 2022-06308
is that motion seconded
i represent mandeville
you're welcome nice to speak on your
motion
thank you mr chairman um
this bill uh this amendment to hb 1076
does a lot of good
uh it removes a lot of the information
gathering requirements that were placed
on the department of labor
dramatically simplifies the bill
and keeps the
main enforcement mechanisms in place
and if i haven't said it before
i just want to publicly say thank you
for the work that you and i both did on
this
i think this makes a good bill better
and i would ask the committee vote in
favor of otpa
thank you
any individuals uh wishing to speak
on the amendment
sing none mr chairman
yesterday have the amendment number
repeated
2022-06308
thank you
you're all set with it call the role
seaworth
yes
avaloni
callum
no
becky
yes
love not here
uh warden
turcotte
wrote
yes
boyd
huff
no
sullivan
yes
susie
schultz
yes
cahill yes
fellows
yes
schmidt
toomey yes
bouchard
yes
educate
yes minimal yes infantine yes
15 to 5 passes
for the amendment's past is open to
further uh motion
mr chairman yes uh move otpa on hb 1076.
seconded by mandeville
you recognize the speaking motion
i think mr german um
i think that this is a very good piece
of legislation now
that ensures that rights that are
already enshrined into law
for bathroom breaks and
meal breaks and rest periods cannot be
denied
due to productivity quotas um and i
think this provides a lot of
transparency to new potential employees
uh as to what productivity quotas they
would be subject to
uh with that being said um i move otpa
on this and i would encourage the key
committee to vote yes
anyone else like to speak on the motion
wow okay seeing none please call the
roll
seaworth
no
avilani
callum
no
mackie myself no
love not here still
uh warden no
turcotte
no
bro
no boyd
huff
no
sullivan
yes
susie yes
schultz
yes
cahill
fellows yes schmidt
yes toomey yes
bouchard
yes
adjutant
yes mandeville yes
infantine yes
11 to
9.
motion passes
yes don't know i'm waiting for someone
to say if they'll be doing preparing the
minority report
sure
there will be a minority report
correct
next bill house bill 1088
relative to employment protection for
kobe 19 in the workplace
representative um
uh huff you're recognized for a motion
thank you mr chairman um i move that we
render hb
1088 an act relative to uh employee
protection from coven 19 in the
workplace and expedient to legislate i
ask that my motivation is seconded and i
asked to be able to speak to my motion
seconded by representative warden you're
recognized to
speak on your motion
thank you mr chairman
while i applaud the author's attempt to
grant people the freedom to be
vaccinated and or use ppe in the
workplace
such freedom already exists and it is
not the government's purpose to grant or
deny individuals medical choices
so this bill
would seek to disallow discrimination of
which we see no evidence of here in new
hampshire furthermore it does not
address discrimination in accordance
with like protected classes finally
new hampshire is an at-will state
as far as working
and this bill is just not necessary
folks can get a vaccination and they see
as they desire so
i ask that you itl this thank you
thank you
representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um i'm going to um oppose the itl motion
on the basis that
they're
very well could be some employers out
there who would um
uh
ask their employees not to wear
pppe
um
and uh
i think someone should have a right to
put on a mask if they're trying to
protect their health
so um i
would uh oppose the itl
sullivan representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman i am going to
speak in support of the itl motion
the sponsor
stated while he was advocating for his
bill that it was
possibly unnecessary or at least
probably harmless
and i'm concerned
it's it's just a couple of sentences
it's very broad it applies to everybody
you know what what are we missing
in not giving this a lot of thought i i
certainly agree uh with the previous
speaker that
um an employer probably is wrong to
to take an employee who wants to wear
some sort of protective
face mask or whatever and say you know i
don't like that you can't wear it but
what if it's a safety issue what if the
kind of paper fibrous masks
are a risk because of the temperature of
the machines that that you're operating
in have we
in this language made the kind of
exceptions
that we usually do
when we consider a bill of that's this
sort so i would support the itl if for
no other reason then i don't think this
language is yet fully formed and if we
were to go down this road i think we'd
need to
spend some more time doing it right
thank you
anyone else like to speak
the chairman will um
the the the bill is written um has
inconsistencies
i don't see it
passing any muster of law or have
anything needed the presentation was
inconsistent
after questions were asked
and while we have a number of other of
these bills coming up um
i'm sorry this is this this language is
written it's not ready uh for prime time
it's not ready to be a law and it was
poorly crafted as a bill
so you know other comments motion on the
floors in expedience legislate mr clark
please call the rule
seaworth yes avalani
callum
yes
mackie
love
not here warden yes
turcotte
yes yes
boyd
huff
yes
sullivan no
susie
schultz
cahill
yes
fellows
schmidt
no
to me
bouchard
no
adjacent no
mandible no
infantine
yes
um
i must have counted wrong sorry excuse
me
i love i'm sorry 11 to 9 uh itl yes
correct
no no i must
have a counting issue here one two three
four five six should be a time
it was 21 people
yeah so it's 11 yeah it's eleven nine
twenty right my apologies yeah i did not
hear representative kale as well
um promotion passes
will it be a minority report
you can let me know
next uh bill house bill 1363 relative to
the enforceability of non-compete
agreements in the areas of which
there is determined to be a critical
shortage of workers
represent uh i mean representative
seaworth
uh thank you mr chairman i would like to
make motion of itl
second executed by turcotte you're
recognizing speaking of motion thank you
uh we had two
bills trying to address a very similar
issue
relative to
um non-compete agreements
vaccine mandates in the workplace and
what happens to the employee who leaves
an employer because of it
with
the agreement of the sponsor of this
bill
i'd like to focus
our efforts on
hb 1089
and therefore i'm asking that we itl
this bill is redundant
i was seconded by turkey
sorry gotta get the clerk to
get it try to find his paperwork here my
apology sorry john
emotion on the floor is in the speedy
legislate it was uh seconded
you spoke to your motion is there anyone
else who'd like to speak
for or against emotion
i would like to mention i did speak with
representative roy and let him look at
due to two different bills and he
um
offered that we we should itl this bill
seeing no other individuals wishing to
speak mr clerk would you please call the
role
seaworth
yes
avaloni yeah
callum
yes
mackie yes
love not here warden
turcotte yes
pro
yes
boyd yes
sullivan yes
susie yes
schultz
yes
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
toomey yes
bouchard yes
edgerton yes mandeville yes
infantine
without yes of consent agenda
thank you
i'm okay i'm sorry i just listed i just
can't count that's right
next
14 10
14 10.
next bill will be house bill 1410
relative to cause of action involving
private business entity
representative huff is recognized for a
motion
thank you mr chairman i uh
i move that this bill be itl
um
and i asked for a second and to speak to
my motion representative uh
warden second the motion you recognize
to speak
thank you mr chairman uh this bill was
one of the bills that uh the covid bills
that we'd put together for the sub
subcommittee so um it's uh
been
taken apart and reformulated so this one
is no longer uh necessary so i ask that
you uh it'll this and
that's it thank you
thank you i'd like to also make the last
comment this was um
very convoluted if you all recall
if you were on your way to
the drugstore to get a vaccine because
your local bakery wanted you to have a
vaccine before they would let you into
their bakery and you got into a car
accident in a way
to
get your vaccine
you could
have a cause of action
against a bakery
because you had to go get a vaccine
as well as against the bakery uh if you
somehow became ill because of the
vaccine
and uh
that was just something that um
was a little too broad
we have a motion on the floor of itl
it's been seconded there's no further
comments
mr clerk please call the roll in 1410.
seaworth yes
avalani
callum
yes
mackie yes
love not here warden yes
yes
pro yes
boyd
yes sullivan yes
susie
schultz yes
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
do me
bouchard
edgerton yes
medieval yes
yes
20-0
motion passes on uh house bill 1410
without exception uh
or excuse me
yeah i receptive consent agenda
thank you
house bill 1450
oh to employ health screening
reimbursement
mr chairman i'd like to move ipl
we're just going to give the clerk a
moment here
out of order here that was seaworth
seaworth intercom
bro uh representative seaworth you would
like to uh you recognize to speak to
your motion thank you mr chairman um
this was a bill that with the help of
the department of labor
um
we
were
it was explained to us how
the provisions of the that this bill
would seek to put in are actually
already in law if you go up to the top
of this section
section number three talks about how
medical tests
which would include this this health
screening
um is to be covered by the employer
and
in my opinion and in the opinion of the
department
this law would not be needed so i asked
for an itl
representative did i see your hand
raised did you like to speak no okay
representative sullivan
i agree with uh representative seaworth
thank you for that
do i see anyone else
wishing to speak on this bill
sitting down the motion is uh an
expedient to legislate it's been
seconded
representative uh
mr clark would you please call the role
uh seaworth yes
abelani
callum
yes
becky yes
love not here yet uh warden
yes
darkcott yes
pro yes
boyd
huff
yes
sullivan yes
susie yes
schultz yes
cahill yes
fellows
yes
schmidt yes
toomey yes
bouchard
educated
these two mandeville yes
infantine yes
twenty zero
that objection that consent agenda
just so folks know this schedule um
it is my intent i know we've only been
here a short period of time but um
unless everybody says no i wanted to
take a break at 12 30 so people could at
least get something for 30 minutes
to eat and come back unless everyone
raises their hand and say he says no we
don't want to eat at 12 30.
i just don't want anyone if we go till
three or four being you know
so that is my intent
the next bill i'd like to call is
hb 1508 fn
for every discharge of firefighters
um
i'd like to call on representative
avilani
thank you mr chairman i move itl
second motion explorer is expedient to
legislate
and it is um
seconded by representative turcotte
representative abalone you're recognized
to speak to your motion thank you mr
chairman um it raised a lot of questions
um
from this committee as to how this would
be beneficial
given the fact that there was
nothing that the labor department could
bring to us that it was a problem so um
i would just move itl
would anyone else like to speak on this
bill representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um
i'm going to oppose the ito
i think we all received amendment number
zero six eight one h and um i would move
that amendment if the itl motion is uh
defeated
representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman i uh understood
that the amendment to which uh
representative sullivan referred
clarified the bill so as to make it
applicable only to
appearing for work rather than leaving
work as i disclosed at the hearing i
a
an officer in a small town volunteer
fire department and
i value what
this bill would permit
and so i would support
the
amendment
and an ogp thank you
representative seaworth
thank you i'd
like to speak in favor of the itl
um
as
representative avalani stated during the
testimony the sponsor
said that he wasn't aware of an employee
who had an issue with this in the course
of employment he just thought the lack
of this protection might
deter people who would consider
volunteering from volunteering so i
agree that this is
it's a
possible problem but i'm i'm not sure
we're fixing a problem that's actually
out there
and again it's kind of general language
meant to apply to everyone
um
and and we're not considering
the exceptions that would need to be in
such a law for example if i look to my
right here
what would happen if one day
my friend
called in
10 minutes before his flight was
supposed to take off and said you know
what could you hold my flight i'm going
to be an hour late because i was on a
fire call
i'm just not going to be able to get in
on time
some jobs that works and i think there's
a lot of employers out there that really
support the need
um
for volunteers
in in these services but there are other
jobs that it just can't work it's
incompatible
uh
with the business model and i think that
we as legislators need to leave it up to
the employers to figure that out and
make the decisions of how they will
support
their their employees who also volunteer
appropriately thank you
president of cahill
thank you mr chair i i
i understand the example that my friend
from pembroke has given and i i don't
know that uh
i i think we can rely on the just on the
judgment of people who volunteer for
these roles that they would know that
the job that they have or may take
is inconsistent and i would expect that
you know a person
uh would
would take that into account when
applying for a job and understand that
being a volunteer fireman is an
important role in the community
if they need to have a different job
then i that can't accommodate the
schedule such as an airline pilot or
many others i suppose it would be to
their judgment so i would
i'm in favor of the amendment if we get
an opportunity to consider it
thank you mr chairman um
as representative
seaworth mentioned uh i think this bill
is
trying to fix a non-existent problem the
question i did ask representative
des was how many times was he aware of
this actually being a factor and the
answer was zero
um
also as representative c was
points out that
you can't apply
a broad
bill like this for every
individual
business
or employee out there
i believe we have a system that works
fine i don't believe we need to be
putting our
our thumbs on
employers
i can just see the amount of
legal
potential for lawsuits and uh legal
issues that this would bring in and i
just said
definitely in favor of the ital motion
thank you
president maribel
yes thank you mr chairman i i apologize
for not addressing this in my first time
around i appreciate also
uh representative seaworth and uh
turcottes and cahill's thoughtful
comments on this i should have mentioned
that
while i also remember the testimony
relating to um
the
issues of of finding volunteers to sign
up
i can also say that reading this bill
and the
um and the amendment that it relates to
the question of their turning up for a
uh an emergency
not just to whether or not they decide
to join the force a lot of
employees who serve on volunteer
departments could
if they're called some period of time
prior to their shift
and if it is reasonable under the
circumstances could decide they can't
afford to go to the call because of the
fact that they would have to report
subsequently to work so it's for that
reason also that i support the amendment
and the
an otp thank you
in 1970
my family moved into the little sleepy
town of amherst new hampshire
where there were more hunters and cows
than there were people
we had a volunteer fire department
and later on we got our own ambulance
and our own volunteer rescue squad
and it was the pride of the town
of the individuals that would become
emts and be ready
it was one gentleman who was the chief
who was uh
would
deliver your laundry to you your dry
cleaning directly delivered to your home
employers
wanted
volunteers
to be firefighters
and emts they wanted it because if it
ever happened to them
if they had a heart attack they wanted
to make sure someone was coming if there
was a fire they wanted to make sure
someone was coming
and
it was never a time that i can recall
any problem with employers
not wanting to give people time off to
be able to offer that service
i don't disagree with the concept of the
bill
but our job here in my opinion is not to
necessarily just agree to a concept but
look at what the need is we have had
many bills come in front of us regarding
first responders
and they fill the room
talking about why it's a good idea
and then we get letters and we get phone
calls and we get emails
as to why they want that bill passed
it should be noted
that one individual came and supported
this bill that was a sponsor
not one
volunteer fire chief
has contacted me
or written me an email or written to the
entire committee
so how important is it how much of an
issue is it
if
i do not believe we should be
passing legislation
where no one has come to us other than
one individual
saying that they should have this
i just don't think we should do it i say
i'm all in favor of the volunteer fire
department again i just told you this
lengthy story about my little upbringing
in amherst
okay it was important
i'm glad we had it i have fond memories
of it
um
so
if we don't have a problem
and there's not
i i also haven't heard that we don't
have enough volunteer firefighters or
volunteer emts in these towns because of
their jobs
um
so
i'm sorry i just i can't see supporting
something that we don't have a problem
that we're trying to solve
is anyone else willing
like to speak on this motion on this
bill
representative schultz
thank you mr chair just a question for
anyone who can answer it i assume
the idea also comes from
how um national guard folks are treated
i know that i believe there's a law
protecting them
and their jobs or at least there have
been bills to say that
um
was that part of the since i missed the
hearing is that part of the
the reasoning behind this if there
weren't any specific incidents incident
incidences
is that what
the impetus behind the bill is
the um i will answer the uh there was
nothing related to anything to do with
the national guard or such the
belief was that sponsor put the bill
forth that he had a feeling and a
discussion with at least
a potential
individual who was considering being a
volunteer firefighter and felt that
um
unless there was a bill that would
protect them for being late or not
missing
um
that they needed this to be able to feel
comfortable with volunteering
if anyone disagrees with what i have
answered that question you're welcome to
chime in
representative
love we are already in this bill so you
will not be able to to vote on this
all right
anyone else like to speak on this bill
sitting down the motion on the floor is
itl mr clark would you please call the
roll
seaworth yes
avalani avolani
callum
yes
mackey yes
warden yes
turcotte yes pro
yes
void
off
yes
sullivan
no
susie
schultz
no
cahill
fellows no
schmidt
yes
to me yes
bouchard
edgedon
manival no
infantine
yes
12 8
minority please let me know if there's
going to be
a minority report representative mr
chairman if i could ask
the minority to repeat the amendment
number that they're going to
support
i'm going to try to get through a couple
more bills i know there's not much
discussion house bill 1351.
appropriating certain employers um
recognize representative
seaworth as uh
let's give a second brian i got it 1351.
seaworth you're
recognized for a motion
i move ito
second about representative abalone
you're recognized to speak to your
motion
i'm going to
repeat the sentiment from my fellow
representative this is another um
covid related bill that
has a lot in common
with a number of bills we got in this
session
and i think we're deferring all the
discussion as well as the changes to
house bill 1210
for that reason i ask that we itl this
one is redundant
anyone else like to speak on
i was both 1351.
the motion of the floors and speeding to
legislate so you know more comments mr
clerk would you please call the role
seaworth
yes
avaloni
callum
yes
mackie yes love
gordon yes
turcotte yes pro yes boyd yes
yes
sullivan yes
susie
schultz yes
cahill yes fellows
yes
schmidt yes
toby
richard yeah
adjutant yes
mandeville yes
infantine yes
21 0.
uh exception
on the consent agenda
house bill 13
58.
representative um
i originally had representative
representative prout you were recognized
for a motion
i think you'd like to move itl
motion on the floor is an expedient to
legislate by proud
seconded by representative turcotte
representative prout you're recognized
for your motion to speak to your motion
sorry mr chair which was the bill number
again i apologize that's right nowhere
is 51
58 i believe sorry 1358 i'll give
everyone a chance to find it and
representative brown
thank you mr chairman
um
i think the sponsor had an interesting
idea here and he tried to write an
amendment
to kind of
tone it down and do something that we
could support the amendment didn't come
out of ols as i discussed with him
and so
i think it's uh on him to
continue to let that idea percolate and
bring it back next year
if it's something that
he can
crystallize and get us in a form we'd
want to move forward with but for right
now
i would recommend we vote this bill itl
representative turcotte thank you mr
chairman uh
following up on representative pratt's
comments this was an yet another one of
the bills that we rolled into a
subcommittee
um there are actually
pieces of this that we did include
uh in some form into another bill we
will be talking about at a later date so
i
i'm in agreement on the itl motion
thank you i would also like to add that
there are other
you know
blood tests
in such
taken urine tests taken
after accidents
some
require
some employers require
some insurance companies require
and
this would interfere with that
if it were to pass
seeing no additional comments the motion
on the floor isn't expedient to
legislate mr clerk would you please call
the role seaworth yes avalani yeah
callum
yes
becky yes love
warden yes dirk
yes pro yes
boyd
huff yes
sullivan yes
susie yes
schultz yes
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
to me yes
bouchard
edgerton yes
mandeville yes infantine yes
21-0
without exception and consent agenda
please
thank you
i'd like to bring up house bill
additional six months of unemployment
benefits if you're uh
fired for not taking a vaccination
mr chairman representative abalone
you're recognized for a motion thank you
mr chairman i move itl
motion on the floor is an expedient to
legislate
a second okay
by representative boyd
okay oh no i know i just waited him to
catch up sorry i'm good
you are recognized for your motion
thank you mr chairman um we heard
significant testimony
from
employment securities about adding six
months
it would be a burden on small businesses
that and and all businesses that fund
that
unemployment benefits so for that reason
i would move ito
would anyone else like to speak on
the motion
seeing none emotion on the floor is uh
any experience legislate it's been
seconded mr clerk would you please call
the role seaworth
yes
avaloni
callum yes mackie yes love
yes
gordon yes turcotte yes
yes boyd
yes sullivan
yes
susie yes
schultz yes
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
to me
bouchard
adjutant yes
mandible yes
infantine yes
20-1
without objection the consent agenda
please
i don't know if i'm saying that right
the next bill i would like to address is
house bill
keep
keeping the same vein representative
warden you are recognized for a motion
i move in expedia to legislate on hp
all right so thank you seconded by
representative boyd
has been motion has been made and
seconded
representative warden you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
we didn't hear a lot of testimony on
this one and the bill frankly does have
a couple good points to it
such as permitting an employee to opt
out of medical mandate but unfortunately
there were too many fatal flaws in this
bill
the term medical mandate is central to
it but it was not even defined well it's
too vague and then this bill is the one
that would require
employer
to pay severance equal to two-thirds of
the value of the employee's total
compensation if you guys remember that
there were some questions about whether
that includes
bonuses or commission for those people
who are on full
full commission
and
whether it would run alongside
unemployment benefits so with all those
flaws
i think in excluding to legislate is
appropriate for this and if there's a
problem in the future they can come back
with something a little bit more refined
thank you would anyone else like to
speak on the motion
seeing none the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate and has been
properly seconded mr clerk would you
please call the poll seaworth yes
avalani
callum yes
mackie yes love
yes
warden yes turcotte
yes pro yes
sullivan yes
susie
schultz yes
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
to me yes bouchard
adjutant yes
medieval yes
infantine yes
21-0
without objection to the consent agenda
i would like to
address house bill 1124
federal e-verify and
call on representative sullivan for a
motion
i move itl
motion is itl
don't
all right it's been motion that's been
made um i represent sullivan seconded by
representative soucy you're recognized
to um
speak to your motion
i think in a
committee where we generally don't like
putting uh
additional mandates on um
uh businesses this is unnecessary um
we heard testimony over the errors that
occur with the e-verify system
and could
force somebody out of work for uh
for an extended period of time
unnecessarily and we've got an i9 system
that's effective it works and
it assures that
people who
are not qualified to come to work are
not allowed to work
so um i think this is a bill that's
unnecessary and
potentially harmful thank you
thank you mr chairman um
i will rise in opposition to the itl
motion um
i i have to admit i'm a little bit
conflicted on this because there are
some um
pluses and minuses that go along with it
one of my
very big concerns right now is the
illegal immigration issue
and this i believe would
have some effect on
slowing that down i do see the the
downsides um as representative sullivan
spoke to uh spoke to we don't like
putting
mandates on businesses
once in a while
we have to go against the 100 percent
nothing could be 100 percent and for me
this is one of those
so i will vote against the itil motion
thank you
representative schultz thank you mr
chair i have a question for you and by
the way for the record i really want to
be on this committee in the future so
next time if i'm re-elected i'm going to
put it down because we're the cool kids
so see this is my warm-up you know not
just the bills i've brought to you
um
i'm wondering how many people signed in
in favor or against the bill
and i'm also curious to know among those
who testified
did anyone from the bia or any of our
business leaders address this because
and i will just make a point
it is definitely my impression given how
awful our current immigration visa
status is
our businesses do not have enough
employees
to match the number of visas that we get
in new hampshire
and it is a huge problem and as i
understand it and maybe i should let you
answer the question but
as i understand it from my conversations
with business leaders
uh
especially in our tourism industry in
the summer and in our tech sector
especially in the southern part of the
state this is enormously difficult
and anything that would be in the
category of quote
addressing undocumented immigrants in a
negative way actually also hurts the
existing
workers that they do rely upon and we
actually do too by way of eating the
food or being in a room that was clean
or using the software
i should have let you
answer my questions first
no worries you're allowed to make your
comments as everyone else have an answer
to your question on house bill 1124 who
signed up online 93 opposed for support
one neutral and there were six
uh my recommended notes here six
individuals spoke against it i believe
there's only one who spoke in favor of
it
representative seaworth thank you mr
chairman
i i want to uh respond and nothing
against your comment i i think
um
what you said i heard from some of the
public testimony that we had
i am concerned that some of those who
testified against this bill did a
disservice to their cause
as
as representative sullivan said when he
made the motion
we do have a system
that prohibits employers from hiring
employees who are ineligible to work by
federal law
whether an employer uses e-verify or
whether they use the i-9 system that
does not change who is eligible and who
is ineligible to work
and i was a little concerned that some
of the
people who spoke uh during the testimony
gave the impression that we shouldn't
pass this bill because they wanted more
people who were ineligible to work to
actually be eligible
and i just think that
whether they
they believe that as a matter of policy
or not i don't think that's relevant to
this bill and i think it does a
disservice to our debate on this bill to
imply
that that's a factor as to whether you
should support or oppose this
legislation
thank
thank you
i personally support
i'll go ahead representative smith i
didn't see your hand
thank you mr chairman i think what we
actually heard was in the testimony that
there are people who are new to our
country who are perfectly legal and
ready to to work here
we're seeing a lot of
folks coming in from other countries
looking for what new hampshire offers
and
they aren't in systems yet they need to
start working immediately and running
them through a second database not just
the i9 but the federal database that
keeps track of all of this it takes time
and it's something that a lot of
families do not have
my biggest issue with this is it's
another mandate on businesses small
businesses do not have personnel um
folks to do all of this work for them
this this is intrusive in small business
and i really think that this is
unnecessary because i-9 operates very
well thank you
thank you
representative proud
thank you mr chairman
one of my big concerns with this is
i believe we had discussions around
how practical it is to repeal this
leader if we find it's not working
and that
once a business is required to sign up
with the federal e-verify program by the
federal regulations
it's unclear that they can actually
accomplish that
and
withdraw from the system
and so the prospect that will be
entering into something that we don't
have
a way to tweak or modify or change the
scope of later
is of great concern to me and that's why
i'll be voting itl
i support e-verify but i will be
supporting the itl
in the testimony the thing that bothered
me probably the most
was the comment was made about how
some individuals who are not legal to
and i guess you know you have to be
careful use the right term people that
are not able to um
what was it what was the term i don't
want to say wrong
undocumented thank you
undocumented workers
are treated poorly
that aren't paid well
they're in unsafe situations
so it behooves the fact that why would
we want them to work
here if they are undocumented and
subject to poor wages and unsafe
working conditions so we verify would be
a good thing
however
while we were sitting here
mr berkey
was just able on his cell phone to get
flowers for his wife
make dinner reservations check out
flights and what they were going to cost
so he could take her someplace nice
but we can't do that with the effervite
system
it doesn't know a two-letter last name
it doesn't understand
maybe some
situations where someone
their culture has three names
and that's ridiculous
because
amazon can get something here tomorrow
or anywhere in the country and it seems
uh but we can't seem to figure this out
so while i do support the system i sure
hope someday it gets fixed
um
and it was disturbing to hear that in
states where it's required
a minimal 20 some percent 30 of the
people are utilizing it
so i do support some kind of a system
but just just not quite this bill the
way it's been
presented so
any additional comments
representative berkey
come on your wife is watching she's
expecting flowers she's she's expecting
flowers now when she get home tonight
seeing no additional comments mr clark
would you please call the roll
seaworth yes
avalani
yes
callum
mackie yes love
yes
warden yes turcotte no
pro yes
boyd
huff
yes
sullivan yes
susie
schultz yes
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
toomey yes
bouchard
adjutant yes
minival yes
infantine yes
20 to one
yeah without rejecting the consent
agenda
oh i'm sorry
go ahead representative
yes please yes please
all right it is now 12 30 we have gone
through many of these bills we have five
bills left they're gonna have some
debate um
uh
who would like either just a uh a 15
minute break or 30 minutes uh who would
like 15 minutes and to go on
it would like 30 minutes and then we go
on okay we're gonna take 30 minutes
we'll be back here at five minutes after
one
to finish your
pardon
i'll i'll give you a few i just figured
maybe by this time the uh the cafeteria
wasn't going to be overly crowded so you
can grab something
thank you
oh
i don't think so
i was supposed
going to do 13 82.
i'm gonna talk to love
but he was um professional
yeah
bye
absolutely
i know
is
um
but he thinks he is
i'm really surprised
yes
uh
oh yeah
thank you
yes
um
right
vacations
delicious
is
which is a benefit to her sometimes
sometimes
um
is
and suddenly
so
is
um
yes
who started
um
uh
oh
we
are a little blind
uh
you know i was calling one of these
up
is
it was already
they decided
we were having a private conversation
i was mad that leadership
you should
know
um
just
to say something
the rest of us
he's really upset
i know
oh my god
by the way
additional weeks
goldilocks she was sitting in his chair
and she found it comfortable so that's
the goal
yeah
i'm not sure
at least
not everybody
there's
um
the word
miley cyrus
um
lessons
foreign
is
um
it seems like at a minimum
oh i was so calm when i came in here
today i'm sorry
members of the committee i will
apologize in advance
i spilled chili on my shirt
um i didn't get a chance to eat
downstairs so i'm going to
secretly try to have a bowl of chili
here as we're doing this i apologize
good for you
um
yeah i know
my mom is watching
she said get you back get your butt
upstairs all right we have a number of
bills i'm going to go in uh numerical
order here
um job the clerk
out
um
first bill is
house bill 1053
and i call on representative
mark warden for a motion
i move an expedient to legislate on hp
second
motion is inexpedient to legislate by
warden
seconded by abalone
representative warden you recognized if
you all may recall this
bill would have required an employer to
pay wages and an hourly rate equal to
time and a half to any employee
if the employer called them into
work hours not previously scheduled
pursuant to the employer's normal
uh scheduling procedure
so it was a little bit unclear
what the normal scheduling procedure was
and of course this is going to yet
another mandate on
employers who have all sorts of
different arrangements depending on the
industries they're in and the timing and
the
shifts
and the size of the company we did hear
from a number of associations
representing employers and businesses
who were opposed
and i have to agree with them and their
testimony on this one
let's dispatch it
thank you would anyone else like to
speak representative sullivan
while i kind of like the idea of the
bill
um i think we heard enough
testimony over how
difficult it would be to implement
that
perhaps there's a way to do this but
this isn't going to be it so i would
support the ito
thank you
clerk just found his paperwork so give
me a second here it was uh moved by
warden
seconded by turcotte
yes one of the issues i had with it is
well it seemed to have a good concept
paying time and a half for someone who
um
was called into their normal schedule um
almost felt like um
the employer
it's voluntary time
you know you
if you're not scheduled to come in you
can't come in you're not going to come
in you're away you have plans you're
doing whatever
and trying to entice someone with a time
and a half
um to possibly give up their plans
again we always talk about
trying to be
fair with the workers i just i just
thought it was a dichotomy
anyway
um
that being said
with emotion on the floor is
it expedient to legislate it's been
properly seconded discussion's been had
mr clerk would you please call the role
seaworth yes
avaloni
callum
yes
mackie yes love yes
warden yes turcotte yes
yes boyd yes
yes sullivan yes
susie yes
schultz
yes cahill yes
fellows
schmidt yes domi
bouchard
edgerton now
mandeville yes
mr chair i'd like to change my vote to
know
in a moment please okay
yes okay
and now
schultz
has requested to change her vote okay
uh 18-3
is there any objection to the consent
agenda objection okay objection will be
a minority report yes
very well good
the next bill house bill
relative to
enforceability of non-competes mr
chairman
what
huh okay
you recognize your president okay
oh were you supposed to do
thank you mr chairman
um
sorry for the confusion as i mentioned
earlier uh this morning this is one of
two bills that dealt with a
i think the same problem
this intersection between
the covet vaccinations and
and non-compete agreements
for those of us who were present for the
public hearing i think we
had during that discussion there were
some concerns about the original
language
and uh mr chairman i would like my
motion to be to offer an amendment
right um your motion is
moving amendment number
amendment number zero three seven six
seconded by representative huff
i kind of miss that
all this confusion and uh for members of
the committee i don't know if i
mentioned this to all of you i sent an
email out with a copy of this amendment
earlier this week if you got it
electronically there are also some
copies on the table
this was it's the audience that you
could get it was also handed out to each
individual member
at our last meeting
and i will speak to this amendment
when you're ready just want to get to
make sure everyone has a copy of the
amendment knows what we're talking about
president of fellows and schultz you
have
all right representative seaworth you
recognize
thank you
so as i said in the in the original
testimony i think there were a number of
questions some concerns about the
original language and
we offered that we'd work with the
sponsor to come up with some better
language
i actually did
work with him directly as he was
drafting the amendment that we now have
before us and
i i do think this makes the bill better
i i think this makes it a a bill that we
can get bipartisan agreement
that it will be a positive thing
for new hampshire workers
briefly briefly i'd like to go a little
bit into the context of this because i
think it is important the chairman has
explained to us on
in an earlier meeting
that
this is an area the area of non-compete
agreements that a few years ago
the
new hampshire state supreme court came
down with a ruling that essentially said
that a non-compete agreement cannot take
away an individual's right to earn a
living
and so that sort of hemmed in
the scope
the possible scope of non-compete
agreements from what maybe someone like
me remembers from the 90s where a lot of
companies would just throw these things
at you and they'd be very limiting and
frankly a lot of people said well
most of that's unenforceable anyway
the supreme court ruling uh delineated
some limitations to that and then
subsequent to that we passed a couple of
laws that further limited it
um
in
2014 we passed a law that required
disclosure so you cannot enforce an
agreement unless you've provided the
full language of that agreement to an
employee before they agree
before you bring them on as an employee
then in a couple years later and it was
mr chairman you were not in the house
but you came to us as a
knowledgeable citizen and helped us get
the language right we passed another
bill
that
said that
non-compete agreements were
unenforceable for low-wage employees and
we defined in that law what we meant by
low wage it was up to double the federal
poverty level
and in additionally we had a we passed
another more narrowly targeted law
uh for the medical industry to deal with
some very specific issues they were
having there
so
that's the context in the state law
we've kind of
walled in when you can
apply a non-compete agreement as the
chairman mentioned
in an earlier session it's it's kind of
at a good balance now
during the testimony it was explained to
us
that
even the original bill language the
sponsor thought it was merely restating
what case law already applied and in
this case he cited the the federal law
and with the federal law there's this
term material change the terms of
employment
that will result in nullifying a
pre-existing non-compete agreement
and
i just want to be clear i am not an
expert in this i'm i'm not a labor
lawyer i
please take everything i say
as someone who has tried to
research this on their own
but if i understand this the example
that i found was so someone's hired and
for for a
nice salary and part of that is that
they sign a non-compete agreement and
and you may make the decision that yes
for for this amount of money i'm willing
to potentially
sign away my rights for a couple of
years
then later as you're employed the
employer comes back and says you know
what we're cutting your salary in half
well that no longer looks like a good
deal and the courts have held that that
will nullify the agreement that you
signed under one set of conditions that
now no longer apply
in this amendment i tried to change the
focus of the bill
from this
covet vaccination
to that particular issue
and it starts out talking when there is
a material change of employment
then that
requires that you either renegotiate any
non-complete
non-compete
contract that's already in place or the
the previously signed non-compete
no longer applies
um
i did
working with the sponsor we did leave in
the the language about um
we expanded a little because one of the
questions was you know what did it
exactly mean
so it now says um
i just lost it
about medical intervention uh medical
testing and vaccination
we left that in there that was the
intent of the original bill
again the the sponsor said he thought
this is already
the existing terrain based on case law i
i would agree with that
and so i don't think it changes anything
to make that specific and
and comport with the original intent of
this bill
and i would say in the broader sense
this
this expectation that a material change
would nullify an existing non-compete
i think it is practically speaking
how things are we're not really changing
the way
the legal environment surrounding
non-competes but what we are doing is in
some cases the the department of labor
will will now be able to get involved in
issues that formally would require a
civil suit and going to court and i
think that's consistent with the bills
that we've already passed in this area
um
the disclosure one comes to mind and i
think it's consistent with
uh what we like
our department of labor to be able to do
in cases where employers and employees
have a dispute
so
i'll now hear if i'm right about that
but i hope that this amendment changes
the bill
if you didn't support it before to be
something that
that hopefully everyone can agree with
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
i'd like to ask a question on that if i
could
and that would be
the new language delineates medical
testing vaccination and medical
intervention
as
shall be considered a material change is
it the intent of this language that
it is not exclusively for those three
items but it would actually apply to any
material
change
thank you mr chairman um
and in fact the deputy commissioner
asked me the exact same thing when i i
asked him to review this and the way i
read this it is in addition
so it's any material change and then
just make sure to clarify that these
things are included
additionally
or well and as i said i think they would
whether you stated or not
i would expect those things to be
included but this clarifies that so
there will be no question
thank you mr chairman just a question
for uh representative seaworth if the
chair would allow
yes
um it's line 12 on the amendment at the
will of the employer could you just
define what that means
um so
the way i understand this and i did i
did speak with the sponsor before he
drafted the amendment i if it's
the exact wording he came up with
so
if you
one might wonder if i
am asked to sign a new non-compete
because there's been a material change
in employment and i say you know what i
i'm i don't find these new terms
acceptable i i won't sign
can the employer say
because seaworth didn't sign he's
quitting
and
whatever implications in terms of a
lawsuit that might imply
and the the intent of the language is
that the employer is required to come to
a new agreement
uh regarding a non-compete if in fact
that non-compete is a condition of
employment it puts the onus on the
employer to come to terms
and
it's
to my mind it's a bit of a bone we heard
about this
regarding another bill a different
subject
but in some cases these
labor disputes will end up on two
different tracks with the department of
labor
the fact that the department of labor
will be involved with this does not take
away your right as an aggrieved employee
to file a civil suit and attempt to
recover whatever damages are appropriate
the department of labor on the other
hand is dealing with the employer so
that same employee might file the suit
and then call up the department of labor
to report the problem in which case the
department would give a warning to that
employer you know you're
forcing people to sign contracts that
you can't have them sign
they might work with them to try to get
that situation corrected
and
if the employer still continues to be a
problem there might be fines levied
against them
but in most cases the department of
labor isn't going in and
finding corrections
that will help the employee
and
so part of the reason why i suggested
language to this effect is it does give
a little more to the employee who's
who's has a problem with this process
as they engage in whatever
whatever they're going to do to try to
get things right with their employer it
gives them a little more
clarity that
the fact that they didn't sign this new
agreement is not quitting it is a
termination by their employer
given that it's after well
given that this at the will of the
employer would that qualify for
unemployment
interesting question and um
i i'm not going i'm not going to try to
be definitive in this uh i would
actually like to
hear it from the experts from this i'll
give both sides of the story one is
that is what this implies here
the other side of it is this is not in
the employment securities law this is in
the wage and hours law
it's specifically under
the non-compete section
so
would
employment securities consider this law
outside of theirs to be binding on them
that would be a question
um that i'd look to
the department for a definitive answer
thank you mr chairman
i have another question from mr seaworth
so it might correct an understanding
that uh
an existing non-non-compete agreement
uh
would require that did not include all
the possible things that could happen in
the world such as a pandemic
if for example you you operated a uh a
medical practice and you're you hadn't
maybe your doctor has agreed to annoy
and compete for and they had to get
certain vaccinations and treatments but
they didn't list all of them and
something new showed up with a new uh
with a new greek letter
or name
uh you'd have to get a brand new
non-compete at that point you couldn't
just have a broad
non-compete that says you'll get
whatever is whatever the cdc recommends
that was for you
yes
and uh thank you for for that question i
i do think it's a good question
and
um it would depend on the individual
case so you have there's actually two
things that apply here there's your
terms of employment
and the terms of the non-compete clause
and either of those could be as narrow
or broad as the employer
wants them to be
so
yes in a hospital it might well say a
condition of employment is you get all
the vaccines as as recommended by the
cdc
and and they
an employee knows that going in
as
that shrinks or grows based on uh what's
going on in the world that hasn't
changed
to my mind again the the terms of
employment
on the other hand it could be written
another way they could be very specific
about what the terms are
and a
a change to one of them would be
considered that a material change
so
it doesn't exactly answer your question
i think it it it could work both ways
and
it would depend on the details
of the agreement with the employee and
the the non-compete agreement
follow-up to sure
uh
would it be reasonable to to request a
some sort of amendment exempting medical
personnel
at this point
you're off
at this point you know there's no
amendments um this is an amendment to
the bill this is the only bill in front
of us this is the only amendment in
front of us today and we will be
executing today so
in the future a possible amendment
possibly if this passes in the senate
might be appropriate but
i'm not going to hold
uh executive session today and uh wait
for an amendment representative
thank you mr chairman
it's okay if i
respond to
so part of this i'm presenting the
amendment but i'm i'm
thinking about the sponsors of both of
these bills and i think but i don't know
that at least one of the bills maybe
both of them were concerned about
the situation for medical
workers
that
what was happening is
people were finding that they had these
new mandates imposed at a medical
facility that they disagreed with
and so fine i
i'll leave and go work somewhere else oh
but you can't
because
there's this non compete agreement that
doesn't let you leave and go somewhere
else so i think
at least for some of the sponsors and
and i as i said i can't really speak for
them
the issue of the medical worker is
central to what they're trying to
address and remember this isn't a
broader issue of can you fire someone or
or can you require
an employee to do certain things this is
addressing the issue of the non-compete
agreement and when can you tell someone
you know what you can't go across the
street and get another job even though
we're basically forcing you out the door
representative mandeville thank you
thank you mr chairman i'm going to vote
in favor of the amendment um because i
think that's the best practice when as
here
it is clearly an improvement over the
original
even though i will pose the bill as
amended
thank you
representative fellows
thank you mr chair i'm just wondering if
there's a this the amendment uses the
term
material change in terms of employment
is that
defined anywhere in statute
because if it's not it would just apply
to what it says here i i tried searching
i i couldn't find find it
but that isn't i'm not saying that it's
not there just because i couldn't find
it
i think we may have an answer for you
i
think material change is what they would
call a legal team a legal term of art
i think you would find that in
a term that attorneys use in writing
contractual language
and that sort of thing
it may not be in the rsas but
material change is is something
attorneys use quite frequently
representative cahill yes uh just to mr
shortcut would that term of art be
because it's kind of vague and
not not succinct
there are a lot of legal terms of arts
that are intentionally written that way
so i would say this that could be
exactly the
point
representative seaworthy if i may too
and
not
i think that's
representative turcotte is exactly right
on the legal side
i think we also can find cases in
the department of labor
where
we're relying on them to look at the
individual situation and the details of
the case and intelligently decide well
in this case for this employer and this
employee
does that change meet what we think is a
material change to the terms of
employment and i i think
it would
make
the bill worse to try to define that
at the rsa level
because we really want
the department of labor
to be doing that analysis
on a case-by-case basis and i i think
their process of adjudicating disputes
between employer employees shows that
they're well suited to make those kind
of decisions
i have a question for the vice chairman
i'm going to outline a few different
things here and then
ask you a question
lines 8 and 9 clearly state if an
employer makes any material change to
the terms of the employment for any
employee any existing non-compete
agreement shall be enforceable against
such employee
okay pretty clear then you get down to
this line 12. new requirements for
medical testing vaccination or other
medical interventions established by the
employer as a condition of employment
well osha requires
people that
remove asbestos and lead paint to be
tested
at the beginning it's called a base test
and they test them every x amount of
period because they want to see if
they've ingested a certain level of
either asbestos or lead
and if they do then they say okay you
got to back off doing this because
you're ingesting too much of this
somehow
um
i
was required by my employer
to receive a vaccination when the
legislature asked me to go abroad
um because of the country we were going
to
so keep those things in mind
don't even think about
covid because covert vaccination is not
a vaccination by definition so it's not
even covered here
then you go down to this last
three lines
15 16 and 17.
so up here you say these non-competes
and material changes you're out of your
non-compete
but then you say any other employment
agreement including confidentiality mis
disclosure trade secrets intellectual
property whatever are full force in
effect
most of these agreements are
multi-paragraphed
one is a non-compete one is a
non-disclosure
okay
so
i need to make sure
that
no matter what material
change
whether osha requires it or whether
something else then when we finally get
down to the all this really important
stuff
trade secrets intellectual property
customer lists all that other stuff is
still protected
and that's quite cute
um
and
yes that was
when when we discussed this in public
testimony that was a key
those that seem to be
leaning toward supporting the original
bill that was a key component of their
support that this wasn't broadly just
nullifying any contracts that employer
had with employee
but that
all these things would be exempt so that
language has been left in i think it's
the the original language as the bill
was submitted it was certainly my
reading of it that
it it retains the
the original force that all it's making
clear that all of this only implies to
the non-compete portion and does not
affect
any of these other things
very well thank you
are there any other questions or
comments
um and and just so you know when an
amendment's brought to the table by by
um any member of this committee it is
appropriate
to ask questions so
um that's all well and good so don't
feel
concerned about doing so
seeing no other
hands we have a motion on the floor of
excuse me with motion
to pass amendment number
two to two thousand twenty two zero
three seven six h
emotions been made second and discussion
is complete
mr clerk would you please
call the role
seaworth yes
avaloni
yes
callum
becky yes
love yes
warden yes turcotte
yes
boyd
huff
yes
sullivan yes
susie
schultz
cahill yes
fellows
schmidt
yes
to me
bouchard
adjutant yes
mandeville yes
infantine
yes
21.
the amendment has been passed the uh
bill is open to further amendment
representative seaworth i'd like to make
the motion ought to pass as amended
emotion on the floor's out to pass
amendment is seconded by
second second by representative avalani
is open for discussion or questions oh
you need to speak emotionally i'm sorry
and and not to belabor the point i as i
said i think this amendment
um vastly improves the bill
i think it changes it from a political
hot potato to something that actually
protects workers rights
in the past this committee has had some
concern about non-compete agreements and
over-application of them
and this provides one more protection
to a worker who feels trapped by an
inappropriate non-compete agreement
representative manneville
thank you mr chairman i uh uh will
oppose the uh uh ought to pass on um
hb 1 108 9.
um some of the points have been
discussed already i wanted to wait till
we were talking about the bill before i
weighed in on them
the question of
what a material change is certainly is a
concern to me as we all know when
lawyers are looking at
at legislation that might be unclear
they will look at legislative history
that will include
representative seaworth's reference to
the case
that defined or mentioned
material in this respect they'll refer
perhaps to representative turcotte's
description of lawyerly
work they'll relate to they'll
refer to the
plain meaning of it all of which could
be in conflict with each other and will
create potential
additional hurdles in terms of
the ultimate resolution of what is a
contractual right
being
one for a non-compete clause
where this bill talks about
there being established new requirements
a point to a to which i think the
chairman was referring
um
regarding medical testing etc
while there might be questions about how
that would apply at a minimum it would
also serve in my view to discourage
uh the creation of new requirements that
would respond properly to emerging
circumstances which would create another
problem for this bill
and finally i would uh note in my
opinion that the
place for dealing with
overreach or
other
in improper applications of uh
non-compete clauses are in the courts
not in the labor department uh or by way
of statute uh this being a contractual
um arrangement between parties as they
entered into an agreement again there's
a lot of protections for low
income
persons and otherwise in pre-existing
legislation
there's the concern that i think
both private parties and legislators
have with regard to how much protection
there can be for
such things as
confidential information
customer lists and the like obviously
as the chairman's pointed out there are
other
aspects of non-competes but they can
they can cover
the distribution of
documents for example but people bring
with them
pertinent information important
information
and
the
legislature shouldn't be in my view
intervening in that respect so i for
those reasons i oppose this legislation
thank you
for the record since you brought it up
black's law dictionary
um
defines material change as a
representation relating to matter which
is so substantial and important as to
influence the party to whom
made the change
if that helps or not
that's extremely definitive right yes
not subjective at all i don't know
representative mandeville sorry but i
uttered as we both know in the insurance
industry it is defined to mean anything
that would change the rate or the
decision of the underwriter to accept or
reject a risk that's a fairly more
narrow definition
are there any other comments
i'm just contemplating whether i'm going
to say something okay it takes time
i'm very reluctant
um
to mess with don competes that's why
people are going to non-piracy
agreements
i don't care if you want to compete if
you take something you got to pay for it
that being said the motion on the floor
is ought to pass with amendment has been
seconded are there any additional
comments before we go to a vote
seeing none
mr clerk please call the role
seaworth yes
avalani
callum
yes
mackie yes love
warden no
turcotte yes
pro yes
boyd
huff
yes
susie
i'm sorry sullivan
yes
susie
schultz
yes
cajo
no
fellows
schmidt
no
to me
bouchard
accident
yes
mandeville no
instant time
i gotta break the tie huh
all right no no
yes
uh 13 8.
motion passes
i expect a uh
a
minority report
house bill
next on the list is hospital 1094
relative to employee work schedules
just hold off a second before i call on
someone we'll get the clerk settled
awesome
call representative turcotte for a
motion
thank you mr chairman i move itl on hb
1094.
second motion on the floor is in
explaining to legislate
made by turcotte seconded by avilani
you're
recognized to speak on your motion
thank you mr chairman we heard much
testimony from uh business industry they
were unanimously opposed to this bill
a lot of the issues dealt with
businesses
that had
were influenced by weather conditions
one individual talked about the
paving industry we had commissioner
jasper talk about the
agriculture industry again they were all
in unanimous opposition to this bill
there were also some a lot of
issues with the bill itself mechanical
issues
picked out employers with 10 or more
employees
in the state or two more locations i had
a question on that is okay if you have
two or more locations and you only have
two employees at each of those locations
and they still require even though the
total is less than 10. there's just a
lot of things in here that just makes
this bill unworkable and i recommend itl
on them
thank you
any additional comments
on the last bill i talked about an
incentive you know time and a half in in
in
lines 14 through 16 they talk about
compensating someone
um
one and a half times their rate if it's
if they're made to work in the rest
period well
if you're tired
a regular time you're gonna be tired at
time and a half and it doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense
any additional comments
representative
thank you mr chairman and and for
bringing that up you would also violate
section one on page two and you would
have a fifty dollar fine if you made
somebody work in your on their day of
rest
so i have to pay them pay i pay a fine
and i pay them time and a half right
america is a wonderful country
all right anything else
yes representative sullivan
um
i think this uh bill came from a
well-intended sp
place but uh
it's just
too unworkable too many problems i
really don't like it when somebody puts
two different completely different
issues in one bill because you might
like one but not the other and um there
should have been two bills but besides
that i'm going to oppose
i'm going to support the ico
any additional questions or comments
excuse me
seeing none
um
emotion
it's on the floor it's been seconded
proper discussion mr clerk would you
please call the role sue worth
yes
avalani yes callum
mackey yes love yes
gordon yes
yes
no
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt no
to me
bouchard
adjutant
mandeville yes
infantine
yes
18-3
turn the objection to consent agenda
objection
so noted there will be a minority report
um
with three more bills ahead of us uh
we are not allowed to add any other
bills today because it was not in the
calendar so even though we have another
bill that's itl
by the sponsor of this committee uh we
cannot hear it uh and representative
sullivan needs to be somewhere four
o'clock so we're trying to adhere to our
schedule getting out of here in an hour
so
um the next bill on our agenda mr clerk
is house bill 1251 prohibiting payment
of sub-minimum wage
and i call on representative turcotte
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move hb 1251 ito
is there a second on the motion
representative hoff seconds the motion
motion's been made and second and
representative turcotte you may speak to
your motion thank you mr chairman um
we have seen over the years
i don't want to go as far say dozens of
these similar bills but many many many
times we've seen this bill come
or variations of this bill come before
our committee
i always like to point out two instances
where
politicians and bureaucrats have gotten
in between um the
employer and the employee relationship
and this is uh the example i always give
one of them is i guess would be about
four years now maine politicians decided
they knew what was best for the
employees who made tips and uh in the
service industry and decided they would
uh do a similar bill and institute a
minimum wage for those individuals those
individuals soon found out that they
were actually making less per hour than
they were when they were being tipped
they formed an association and they got
the main legislature to overturn what
they had just passed the previous year
back to the the other way my second
example is the last one one my last term
here
when we had a
similar uh bill i won't say exactly but
similar we had an individual testify an
owner of a pub in dover called the
seventh settlement
and he came here in an attempt he wanted
to be one of the first to implement a
straight across the board fifteen dollar
minimum wage for all his employees
whether you're a dishwasher you were a
server you're a bartender didn't matter
everybody got 15 an hour
we used to my wife and i used to
frequent that pub it was excellent
as soon as they implemented this guess
what happened to service it went
downhill
less than a year later they shut down
the restaurant and a short time after
that they had to close the entire
establishment we've got a very good
system we've heard
from individuals in the service industry
already that
the average uh tip minimum wage is
somewhere up around 20 an hour i know
for a fact because i have two individ uh
son and daughter who both worked in that
industry that that number can far exceed
20 an hour
um and can be almost amazing how much
individuals can make
as servers or bartenders so
for all those reasons uh we've got a
system that works now we don't need to
be changing it and i recommend itl
thank you representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman
i am going to oppose the itl
the uh and i want to also uh correct one
um misconception this bill does not ban
tips
um this bill um provides for tipped
workers to earn at a minimum the true
minimum wage um they would then earn
tips on top of that
um
and
i
know that a lot of restaurants
um
are struggling to maintain their their
uh their workforce um some of the
restaurants i like to frequent are
closed on some nights of the week
because they don't have enough staff
um so um i think um
uh this would assist with that problem
you would and frankly there are quite a
few restaurant owners that have
seen the light and are already paying
people well over the current minimum
wage
so um even though they earn tips on top
so
i support the uh concept i will oppose
the motion thank you
thank you representative
thank you mr chair um i will reiterate
that i did write this bill
with input and i did recently work for
an organization that was fighting for
uh ditching the subminimum wage at the
federal level i did not earn any money
to do any of this work but for i just
want to be upfront about that
in case anyone has any concerns um so
there is the caveat
um
there are actually eight states
to counter the main
uh the state of maine argument eight
states who have ditched the minimum sub
minimum wage for all of their workers
it has been great for them
they include the super woke states of
nevada that was a joke by the way nevada
montana minnesota hawaii oregon
washington alaska and california and by
the way california is now considering an
minimum wage
uh which i find interesting
uh the darden corporation board chair in
a call with investors
said
when asked about
this movement to ditch the subminimum
wage
said actually the restaurants in those
states were better
so
keep that in mind and i have
if i go any further i'm probably just
really repeating my testimony i just
want to make the point though too i just
emailed you if you have a smartphone or
currently refreshed a device for your
official
email
there are instances since we met
in the actually one of them may have
been in the news
we had a
former restaurant worker testify that in
fact she had not been paid what she
thought she was supposed to be making
not even just the tips but even the base
wage and it was very confusing
and then i realized later that
i hope he doesn't representative
seaworth was talking about the same
restaurant and very dismayed with their
business practices
also this past week it was in the news
one of my favorite restaurants here in
concord
uh
held back 62 000
worth of tips
that are owed to those workers
i know that the majority of restaurants
in this state are wonderful
with great business practices they
probably treat their employees well and
it's certainly a tough time to be a
restaurant owner or bookkeeper
i'm not naive to that
but this is an antiquated system from
the jim crow era that really has to go
and we were smart about it when we
ditched the subminimum wage for workers
with disabilities
this would be a similar advancement and
just doing what is the right thing in my
opinion but
even financially it's better but i'd
like to make a suggestion
knowing that there are two recent
really awful stories and knowing that
this is a complicated time for the
restaurant in
industry and for workers would you be
open to interim study on this topic on
this bill
sure
and of course someone making the motion
uh itl could withdraw the motion as well
i'm just throwing this out there because
it does affect
um
well at least two of us this is in our
district the issue that's growing and i
believe that the confusion around this
issue
for even restaurant owners and workers i
think that
you know if it's not going to pass i do
think we should look at pay
and today's market and also i'll add
there are some
servers tipped workers who do make great
money they tend to be at the higher end
restaurants
they tend to not share those tips with
back of the house
plenty of our restaurants do not do that
well i wish they did this wouldn't you
know them i doubt anybody would have any
problems with the way things are going
but
we need to level the playing field
because this
type of law would in fact
not
the restaurants who have
the easy ability and flexibility are in
competition with the mom-and-pop places
and if we don't level the playing field
it actually hurts the entire industry
and as much as i like the free market
and adam smith and all those analogies
our free market doesn't always account
for
greed and misunderstanding you know for
those of us who see
not a worker shortage but a wage
shortage or a benefit shortage
this is definitely one of those issues
that deserves discussion because it ends
up hurting our small businesses this mom
and pop restaurants the most
and i spoke more than i meant to but i
just wanted to make the case that you
could withdraw the motion and go for
interim study but i respect the chair
and and the motion that is on the table
thank you mr check
um i wanted to point out and it does fit
in with the
immediately previous comments there are
two issues here one is the policy and
we've had bills
addressing this policy before and
there's a policy debate
that
people in this room come on one side or
the other
i'd like to also focus on the specific
language of this bill
during the testimony there was
i i heard a lot of confusion i didn't
hear the answers
um
this takes
the 279 22 what's a paragraph in current
law and replaces it with a sentence
and i i saw a lot of
people wondering what exactly that would
do i mean obviously it's intended to
address the tipped wage
but what else does it do when all that
language just vanishes
from the books
and so for that reason
i appreciate the policy discussion but i
would also
warn that i i'm not i haven't seen any
amended language to address that i
haven't heard answers as to exactly what
the implications or fan out of this is
so i would caution the committee um
those who
are might advocate for an otp on
from that angle
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
one of the issues that was brought up
with the subminimum wage is under no
circumstances in a if you're a server
even though there's a
the server minimum wage is down in the
three dollar
area
under no circumstances can they never a
server never get paid less than 7.25 an
hour which is the federal minimum wage
so
to say that somebody can make three
dollars and whatever the number is 23
cents or whatever it is right now
that is not supposed to happen if it
does happen then the
employer is supposed to make up the
difference
yeah we have seen a couple of instances
in the news recently
about a couple
individuals
those were perfectly handled by the dol
exactly what they're supposed to be
doing they
created the settlement
as to uh supply and demand in the free
market uh which i espouse uh frequently
it's not an analogy that's economic
principles that's
free market does work and supply and
demand does work thank you
representative hoff
and then i'd like to speak and then i'll
call you again representative and then
okay
all kinds of it's all over the place
representative huff and let the people
who spoke first representative hoff
representative
adagent and representative schultz
thank you mr chairman i was just
pointing that your microphone wasn't on
i oh that was an easy quick one
thank you mr chairman um i don't want to
specifically direct this question that
representative turcotte but it was
something that he mentioned
um
yes it is true that
the
that a server cannot be paid less than
725 an hour
i guess
i'd ask a question if anybody wants to
answer it then if that's the case what's
the point of having a subminimum wage if
a person cannot legally paid be paid
less than the minimum wage
what is the purpose of having this
arbitrary number
at three dollars that the employer has
to make up the difference to anyways it
just seems like putting a hat on a hat i
can't really square that as to why it
would be necessary to keep a subminimum
wage if they can't be paid less than the
federal minimum wage
when i speak i'll give you an answer
representative
tui
yeah
when i was uh
younger a long time ago the customary
tip was 10
over the years that evolved and it
became 15
now it's 20
more of the
responsibility
to pay a server
falls in
in the customer's hand now
and this doesn't stop
tipping all it does is
maybe
create a mechanism where
the employer would be more responsible
for paying the employee
and le and the customer less responsible
but still responsible
thank you
president cahill did you want to speak
you've got to get me some of those um
those the mirror thing so i can see you
guys on the other side i want to get to
everyone first before i get back
representative abalone representative
schultz after
thank you mr chairman we were um
the representative schultz has sent us
the um
yes
you read it from the patch yes
it is illegal to split tips with your
supervisors
it's also illegal to split tips with the
back of the house
it's also illegal to split tips
or withhold tips from your employees
so
trying to redistribute the tips to other
members of your employees who do not
earn them
would be a direct violation of state and
federal wage laws
so we can take that if anybody wants to
read the tip regulations under the fair
labor standards act
it was just rewritten april
and any
responsible
business owner that has
a restaurant would know that you can't
take your employees tips
i did speak to the department of labor
about this but i'm going to let
representative schultz speak and then i
will tell you about my conversation with
the department of labor
representatives i'd rather hear what you
have to say
um i appreciate this discussion very
much i just want to clarify a couple
things
and i'm happy that i forgot more
that i was going to say because
i've talked i've spoken a lot but
the um to answer representative
adjutant's question about why does this
system exist
um
there are so many articles on this so
all you need to do is google the phrase
jim crow and sub minimum and you will
get a slew of well-documented
well-substantiated
accounts of why and it is from
the post-slavery era and how do we
[Music]
bring all these folks who weren't
getting paid and doing work that they
felt needed to be done as slaves and not
pay them well we will make them
dependent on
uh if they are well behaved and nice
then their whole wages will be paced
on their tips
tips were already accustomed here anyway
as they were in europe and other places
but
their entire pay at that point was zero
officially and they literally in a very
in a variety of jobs uh famously
as um
the pullman company the train company
can um in various roles
and in lots of restaurants especially in
the south
uh at some point i haven't memorized
what year
they thought well you know
maybe we should pay something and so
at that point i believe it is in the
last hundred years
the decision was made that paying zero
was ridiculous so that's good but then
they made the sub minimum wage category
for that maybe there had been some
minimum wage categories already for
workers who with disabilities i don't
know the history of that but certainly
for tipped wage workers
that was the history
and
it still means that their pay is
dependent on
the grace and kindness or feasibility of
their customers
and i didn't even get into the issues
that that raises with sexual harassment
because that has happened to some tipped
wage workers here in new hampshire and a
lot of other problems
but
most servers get a paycheck that still
says zero
and so from the slavery days to today
new hampshire's only gone from zero
dollars to three dollars and 27 cents
and while the law i appreciate the
clarification on the law of what and how
people are paid
um
the easiest way to fix all of these
confusions would be to just get rid of
it and pay people the same way we pay
them everywhere else not to get rid of
tips
i would say fifteen dollars plus tips on
top but for the purpose of this bill it
would be seven dollars and 25 cents
plus tips
um and this discussion is so good it
also would be great isn't it it's an
interim study
anybody else like to speak
all right first off
and answer your question representative
addison um
i suggest you talk to your
congressional delegation and do
something in washington and get rid of
the sub-minimum wage is a good start
and then we can tackle that here
um secondly i knew i figured this
question would come up about dose of
egos and this
this was a federal
dol
investigation in vine
their laws are different from ours
that what they do
would not have is not illegal in new
hampshire
i was one of the co-authors of the
new tipping bill
with uh
former representative murphy and
representative simmons
believe it or not we sat down at a bar
with a couple beers and we figured out
the new tipping laws because our tipping
laws were so
out of date
and
it came up because you know a bar has a
spittoon if you will or some kind of a
jar behind
and and the bartenders all put their
tips in at the end of the night and then
give them out
that was illegal five years ago six
years ago
so we
changed the law to allow for tip pooling
and tip sharing
the number one thing in new hampshire
which has always been adhered to is tips
are the
are owned by the employees never by the
employers
period and the story don't even bring it
up
okay
however
with the new law that we did change
you can have an agreement if you want
amongst the employees if they choose to
say look we will give the the waitresses
will give a certain amount of money for
the uh bus bus boy or the um um
person to sit you down i can't think of
right now
hostess or whatever so that that is
allowed so there is some of those things
that are allowed but when it comes to
this dose of me goes understand
um if you ever been there i love the
place
you start here you order you go down you
watch them make it
and then it's there and there's a tip
jar
and the managers work just as hard right
next to
the employees
and they felt that they were following
the law which they were according to new
hampshire
but apparently we have some
disagreements with the feds on that
um
so just to just want to clarify what
that situation i asked
rudy ogden
assistant bishop ogden
why this came about he had not heard
from the feds about this and why the
investigation was brought forth
but it was not brought forth by the
state of new hampshire
so i just want to clarify some of those
things
did i get the tipping law correct
yes
because believe it or not a employer
came in front of us and sat in front of
the committee because they were finding
the department of labor
for again having that one
container behind the bar where all the
bartenders a very busy place would take
all the tips and put it in at the end of
night share it they got fine that was
against the law well that was being done
in every single
establishment in new hampshire at the
time
so
since then i don't believe there's been
any issues so
that being said
that's all i have to do to say regarding
all the things that were either asked or
brought up representative cahill uh yes
thank you mr that just raises the
question in my mind and i understand the
managers are working hard and the
hostess and everything it's customary to
tip out but are they paid
are they working for tipped wages or
something beyond that the people who
were
as as far as federal law inappropriately
taking a share of the tips
again i i don't know federal law as well
as i know new hampshire law but
according to what we did
if the agreement was made with the
employees to do that those managers were
working right with them
and they agreed to that that is legal in
new haven that would have been legal in
new hampshire i don't know all the
specific specifics of the federal case
just know what we all read in the
newspaper
okay
representative huff
uh thank you mr chair in the interest uh
to representative sullivan would it be
appropriate to move the previous
questions because i'm sure we'll have
this debate more than a million million
more times
um i would ask you to hold that motion
at this point are we all uh is everyone
spoken who would like to speak
what am i looking at oh gosh um
representative and then we'll close it
up if okay
thank you mr chairman i just want to
clarify for the record that the question
that i asked was facetious oh i'm sorry
and i just yeah i couldn't square in my
head how it made sense to dig a trench
at 3 27 when the actual battle line is
at 7 25. uh that was
the kind of open-ended question there
but um
understood and thank you i couldn't see
through your monarch's mask the smile on
your face that you were giving me
saying that we have no other hands um
very
very good debate there is a motion on
the floor
unless it's going to be withdrawn the
motion on the floor is as inexpensive to
legislate seeing no other hands
seeing no other motions
mr clerk please call the roll
seaworth yes
avalani
callum yes
mackie yes love yes
warden yes turcotte yes
yes void yes
yes
sullivan no
susie
schultz
no
cahill no
fellows
no
schmidt
no doumi
bouchard
adjutant
mandeville no
infantine yes
11 10.
i'm sure
unless he knows right now representative
sullivan will let me know
what that'll be
1472.
okay
our next bill house bill 1472
prohibiting anti-union activities and i
would like to recognize record
huff for a motion
uh thank you
mr chairman
um i move that uh we ran into this itl
uh thank you promotion on the floor's
interspeed to legislative hospital 1472
it is seconded by
representative representative
abalone aulani
the motion has been made and seconded
representative huff you were recognized
to speak about your motion
uh thank you mr chair
um this bill would uh prohibit
anti-union activities by employers
um
although i i believe that the uh
the authors are are
have have a a good
heart as to trying to keep fair the
reality is um
an employer is more than free to express
his opinion as to how he would like to
run his his business
and to prohibit his first amendment
right of free speech or freedom to
associate or to try and
make a living
it shouldn't be allowed
by government
um so i ask that we uh itl this bill
thank you
representative bouchard you're most
recognized to speak thank you mr
chairman
and um
in order to
respond to representative huff's
statement i would like to
to agree with him that
employees have their employers
have their
right
to their free speech however
i am going to support this bill because
it will eliminate
employers requiring
employees to attend
anti-union
videos
and
i believe that's the
crust of this bill is to
to eliminate that
thank you thank you representative um
out of gentoomy
thank you mr chairman uh representative
huff is correct in that the intention of
this bill is to uh level the playing
field uh very often and i've worked for
several companies that uh have done this
uh show up the first day uh you're hit
with that video where very clearly
people who've never worked for that
company and are very obviously actors
um are telling you about how unions are
terrible and they'll steal all your
money and
um
it there's something about being on the
clock during those meetings uh that
really enforces
that to an employee
really just want to make sure this is
fair i really just want to make sure the
level level
playing field exists
um i think this is a good bill
i would definitely support a not to pass
motion uh and i hope the itl fails so we
can do that
um
i don't have as much more to say on that
thank you representative toomey
yeah
this has three components to it and i
kind of wish it didn't
you know one it's
an employer can't lock out employees
uh they would have to allow striking
employees
to uh come back to work
and then the other one has to do with uh
forced
attendance meetings uh relative to uh
relative to uh having a union
i'll just limit my my discussion to the
last
you know i i
i think has been said before today you
know it's a good idea to keep
uh your
proposals uh simple and
but having said that
what happens very often
uh
if
there's discussion of having a union all
of a sudden
management
brings in
paid consultants and they hold meetings
and
employees are required to go to those
meetings and in fact they're coerced
to listen
and first of all
if people decide
or want to decide whether they want to
as a group
bargain individually or they want to
bargain as a group
that's their business it's not the
employer's business
and so
they're intervening
into
a process that should be handled solely
by employees
and
so
the employer
if they notice that
employees refuse to go to those meetings
they can fire that employee they have
the ability to hire fire promote demote
uh transfer
put letters in people's files and they
do that when people
try to organize
and so
you know if if an employer wants to
give
employees their opinion about whether
there should be a union
or not
they can send a letter
to employees and and have the employees
look at the
pros and cons of it but when they bring
them into a meeting to
coerce them
intimidate them
in a process that should be handled
solely by the employees themselves
i think that's wrong
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um
just responding to a few comments and a
couple points um currently uh we
it appears that this would be
an attempt to add on to or rewrite
portions of the new
national labor relations act or even the
railway labor act
um
we have things called collective bargain
bargaining agreements um
that if this kindness
these
are big enough issues you could even i
suppose
get those into your collective
bargaining agreements
being forced to watch
this video or that video i can tell you
annually on an annual basis i have to
sit through some uh woke presentations
in my annual training that i'd much for
not prefer to sit through
and the last thing i would point i would
make
is this bill is prohibiting anti-union
activities by employers are we going to
have a companion bill that's going to be
prohibiting anti-employer activities by
labor unions
i am in favor of the itil motion thank
you
thank you
representative huff
thank you i just
i just wanted to make one one small
point um
of what our honorable member from
hillsborough said
he was talking about the employers and
he said it's not their business
yes it is
thank you
you've heard the expression um
you know the system isn't very good but
it's the best one we have there's no one
better one that has been devised
i look at this the same thing when it
comes to
employees establishing a collective
bargaining and creating a union
you're right representative toomey
some of the things that go on
when a
company is looking at having their uni
their employees organized are despicable
but neither one has clean hands
whether it's
videos brought by management
showing up to employees doors
to converse to even some issues with
card checks
um all these other things that go on and
it's not a great system and some of the
things that go on
um
you know
you know some of you are too young for
this a famous movie norma ray
um and some of the things that did go on
that
have gone on
and uh both parties could do it better
no doubt
and a lot of these things shouldn't
happen
i would love to have seen
these
for both
both groups
be more equal
both parties have to do this both
parties have to adhere to that
um
there are certain rules with uh
nlrb has certain
rules and such and how you go about this
but um
i just think this is one sided then you
have to look at both sides um and if
you're going to set a law
requiring
employer not do this and you have to
you have an equal law said says the
organizer can't do that
moves out of sullivan
then results
i think it's important to keep in mind
that there's a power a very distinct
power differential between individual
employees
and their employer
and in the organizing process what you
have is a group of individuals who are
trying to figure out if they want to act
collectively
but before they actually have that
election
they are at a distinct power
disadvantage to the employer
and
issues like this are addressed by this
bill are important to maintain that
or to protect those employees from a
hostile employer and basically
um you know
it was it was mentioned that perhaps
these issues can be placed in a
collective bargaining agreement
not if you don't have one yet
um
you've got to have a
a bargaining unit before you can have a
collective bargaining agreement
and
there are companies out there that we've
all heard about that are
working really hard to make sure and
there are companies that will close down
facilities rather than allow them to
unionize
um and so it is a very hostile
environment for unions these days
which is why
legislation like this
is appropriate
i
i have a couple
representative schultz love that
turcotte
thank you mr chair i just want to
briefly mention the fact that especially
since the reagan era
and what happened between reagan and the
air traffic controllers
began a trend that hasn't stopped and
that is to severely eroding the rights
of workers to
organize and unite
which by the way is on the list of human
rights
what every human should be able to do in
this case every worker should be able to
do collectively organize
but i think we have gone so far astray
on this
and it correlates to the decline of the
middle class and the difficulty
for younger generations to own a home
pay for student loans etc
i i think union membership in this
country is
i don't know
more definitely more than half of what
it was when i became aware
and it's it's really been hurtful and
you can see this in you know i love
talking about anything woke it's always
an interesting discussion
but to
we thought well woke companies amazon
and starbucks
who have targeted especially
liberal-leaning humans to be their
customers
they have been actively doing these
tactics
and to the detriment of their workers
because i don't believe
for the most part that that any union is
quote unquote against the company if
they were
they wouldn't do a very good job as
workers in representing those workers i
think that what it is for
is for the power differential to be able
to listen to and it's not always about
pay or benefits it's often about little
things that maybe management hasn't
thought about
but i i believe um this type of bill
returns to our society
what we've lost over the last
35 40 years and it's overdue
thank you mr chair thank you
representative love followed by turcotte
thank you mr chair um
just a little bit of history um
i i was brought up in a union home uh
you know my dad was a teamster my mother
was a past president of one of the
locals of the ibw ibew
my grandfather's a charter member of uh
teamster local 25
i joined the teamsters in 1974 i'm
currently on withdrawal from
local 633
i've also been a business owner and an
employer and um
you know uh to reiterate what greg uh
representative huff said uh you know as
the employer or if i'm paying you
and i want you to watch a video i'm not
asking you to do anything dangerous
go watch that video
um
you know it's um
like one time
i was on strike i was working for a
company
and what goes what
goes unsaid a lot around here um you
know my i was over my grandfather's
house and uh you know i'm telling we're
gonna get this and we're gonna do this
and we're gonna get it
and he sat there and he started waving
his finger at me he says wait a minute
remember one thing if the boss isn't
making money nobody's making money that
gets lost you know in in union
negotiations and stuff
you know we've got to always remember
that nobody wants the doors closing
that's it thanks thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman um in response to
representative sullivan's
points he was making a lot of points
about organizing i would point out this
bill itself though
talks about in section one it talks
about
an employee participate participating in
a strike the second one is participating
in a strike to lock out suspend or
otherwise withhold employment those all
speak to
incumbent uh union members
who are already covered by collective
bargaining agreement
the the only one that you could maybe
even
relate to organizing is is the
second
paragraph down in line 13 but nowhere in
this this bill does it talk about
organization or organizing a union and i
will go back to
especially when it comes to collective
bargaining agreements and organ
organizing
that in fact the nl rb and the rla are
very
uh
have a lot of information and a lot of
what's what i'm looking for
already contains a lot of the same
information or ideas that this bill is
trying to put into it so again i rise in
favor of the itil
so you know additional hands the motions
on the floor of any speeds the
legislature has been seconded and we've
had appropriate
discussion mr clerk please call the role
seaworth
yes
avalani yeah alum yes
becky yes love yes
borden yes
turcotte yes
sullivan no
susie
rudy
no i'm sorry get away
i ran out of my sheets i corrected yes
cahill no
uh
fellows
no
schmidt
to me
bouchard
mandible no
infantine yes
11 10.
thank you
i'm going to skip to a it would be a
quick bill and then a a quick 10-minute
break
house bill
1569 fn
motion mr chairman totally unemployed
are you looking at me again
motion uh find
hb 1569 ito
motions on the floor is itl
seconded by
seconded by representative uh
boyd
who made it
has been made in second representative
turcotte you may speak to your motion
thank you mr chairman the prime sponsor
of the bill of representative lam came
to the committee and asked that we find
this bill teal
and we also like to speak on
the motion of itl
seeing none the motion has been made
second discussion has been had
mr clerk please call the role seaworth
yes
avalani
callum
yes
mackie yes love
warden yes
yes
boyd yes
uh susie
i'm sorry sullivan
yes
uh susie
schultz yes cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
toomey
bouchard yeah
yes
medieval yes
infantine yes 21-0 all right consent
agenda unless uh
uh
injection all right we're back in
we're going to take a 10-minute
drink and bathroom
uh break
back to our last building
john you're talking a lot today
sorry thank you call the executive
session back into order
we're um the last bill in the docket
today is house bill 1514 fn
i recognize
representative cahill for a motion
thank you mr chair i would like to offer
amendment 2022-0787
h
seconded by representative toomey
motion's been made and seconded
representative cahill you're recognized
to speak in your motion thank you mr
chair
um this is
a bill we've talked about a bit before
and i think the the issues here this is
pruned down to just two instances
where i think many of us might agree
that uh
the employees who had earned their time
lost it through no fault of their own
through actions for which they had no
control no opportunity
to make a difference in this no
opportunity to use the time before their
employment terminated
and in one case actually they continued
working just for a different company on
the very same job something that doesn't
normally happen
and i think the vast majority of cases
in that situation what's done is the
previous employer makes an arrangement
with the new employer to accept the
employees not only the employees the
trained workers but their vacation time
their earned time pto whatever the term
is
that's what's normally done it's not
required under new hampshire law
and when it doesn't happen
what can happen is people lose
whatever they had earned it just
suddenly vanishes from their pay stub
and they're starting from scratch
uh there was a con there was a
discussion with deputy ogden at our
hearing
and that the department has a means of
going after these companies but that's
only if their policy had been stated
that they do pay or transfer the time
when the policy says
uh at termination the term you know
nothing is paid out
then that's that's the uh prevailing uh
that's that's the ruling so in the case
of the i think there were five people
from one one place who did go through
the process
uh they had
they they fought they lost they they had
their game their claims were denied
because of this situation so this bill
this they amended as as amended
would require that the employer
when this when the company is sold
either transfer or pay out
the the time that's what that does the
other instance the other situation
covered by this is a permanent layoff
not a not a traditional layoff because
that was a concern by the seasonal
workers but a permanent layoff you're
not going back
so if again you have time that you've
earned and all of a sudden today's your
last day
whatever you have would be paid to you
because you earned it and you didn't
have an opportunity the policy may have
been obviously if today's your last date
i can't say well let me take my vacation
and i'll come back and work another week
or two that's not an option so this i
think in the interest of fairness
we would pass this bill
so that at least these two situations
would be covered there was additional
language that we talked about before
from our former uh member
herschel nunez which you know detailed a
fairly common practice where if you uh
the employee leaves in good standing uh
has been a good employee and tells the
gives the employer notice that they're
leaving they also don't lose but that's
not in this bill that's not in this
amendment so i request that you
uh pass this uh remembering that the
people who are
affected negatively are our constituents
as well as the business owners
so
i urge you to ought to pass on the
amendment and the subsequent bill
thank you i would also like to speak on
the amendment for representative
sullivan
might be a little premature on this but
i just i i guess
um
representative cahill has been working
on this for a long time
and he's continually compromised
adjusted amended and tried to make this
bill workable for uh
the parties concerned and i
i for one think this amendment gets us
there
and uh finally we should be able to move
on this issue and uh
um
take care of some folks uh who feel
they've earned something um then find
out that
it's gone so um
i want to
commend representative cahill and
uh support this amendment thank you
motion of the table has been made and
seconded for the amendment um
this discussion has been had
mr clerk please call the role
no
yes
amendment passes
11 10.
is there a question donnie
they're discussing that that was the
amendment
there's the amendment
uh the amendment passed the vote the
bill is open for further uh
uh
motion
so chairman i'd like to move otpa
that seconded representative sullivan
you're well you're recognized to speak
to your motion
go to caleb uh yes thank you again mr
chair
um
again the amendment is what i think
right our friend mr gervais calls baby
steps
and uh we hope we hope that this will
address some issues that people
reasonably expect would not happen in
the great state of new hampshire in an
employer or employee relationship
there are numerous cases that are that
are claimed every every year every month
with the department of labor not all of
them are correct all right i think few
of them are under this circumstance but
these these cases i think we should
uh we should address and that's why i
think i put the bill in i hope you will
support it
representative cahill
i
thoroughly appreciate your dedication
to this bill based on
some of the circumstances you brought
forth
you have been
a gentleman
thoughtful
and just a stand-up guy
to me and this committee when i was on
it
and even when i was off the
things you've done
representative sullivan you are correct
that um
the
concessions made over the years
as i explained to you mike
the issue comes down to
you know line 13 where you you feel that
um
you call them earn time i call them
benefits
constitute wages due
and
there were two members
today who have spoken in this chamber
that we don't need to tell businesses
what to do
and
each business is different
and each
business decides that they're going to
give
vacation time
holiday time sick time or just some are
just saying a certain block of hours do
with it what you want
but the reason
many employers give benefits to their
employees such as vacation time or sick
time
because they want
to be good to their employers
employees excuse me and give them a
vacation because they come back
refreshed it's good for them it's good
for for everybody
and it's and
frankly it's the right thing to do
giving people vacation time it's the
right thing to do to give people sick
time
and i'm all in favor of that but
it doesn't mean that it's equal to a
cash out payment
and that's where we have this
fundamental disagreement
i give someone
two weeks vacation
at the beginning of the year and then
they quit the first week
of the year and they want two weeks paid
vacation or they
keep it going
three or four years sick time or
vacation and then leave for any number
of reasons good bad or indifferent and
and they want
that
what i consider a benefit and you
consider earn time
a cash payment for
and that's that's kind of where we
disagree
these six circumstances you talk about
um
my apologies
the circumstances that you talked about
and that we know well
um
are wrong
when
one company was sold to another and they
didn't bring those benefits over
okay
and those things you know hopefully we
have the laws for or those can be
tweaked
but
again i can commend you michael for just
being an
absolute stand-up guy
on how you've addressed this
and and um how you've treated this
committee with these things
and and
the reason why and on two separate
occasions i have
wanted you to have that opportunity
to make your motion and submit your
amendments
um
when i knew that probably the votes may
not be there
because of how you
you know how you
just treated this committee and everyone
i just can't get over the cash out
payment
and it's just too much for me so it
pains me to say i cannot support your
your amendment here
because i don't think we should be
telling everyone these businesses what
to do as i said repeating myself
a couple members of your party said
today about not
telling businesses what to do and that's
a really tough thing we have here in
this committee
all right it's trying to be consistent
and not trying to tell people what to do
but maintain the safety of our
employees and such
so i apologize michael i cannot uh
representative i cannot support your
amendment but
i i sure support your your your
dedication tenacity and gentleman
gentlemen this gentlemanly
uh to me so uh
to me sullivan and then michael i'll
tell you
sorry i shouldn't be calling you by your
first i apologize representative cahill
but it's my opinion yes
all right uh
if you make a deal
you live up to the deal
it's as simple as that
if you don't want the government to get
involved
with the employee employer relationship
live up to your deal
make
make it clear there was a discussion of
flexibility the employer has all the
flexibility in the world
they can
if they decide
to give their employees a vacation
possibly because their competitors are
giving their employees
a vacation uh if they
decide to do that
they can set up all kinds of
restrictions and and and parameters on
it
we talked about it before
you can have use it or lose it
you can have a stipulation that you have
to work for a full year before you can
you can take the vacation you can do all
kinds of things
so if you don't want the government to
get involved
between the employer and the employee
live up to your deal make your deal
clear
and the and
you know that's what i think
the sponsor of this bill is is trying to
accomplish thank you
representative sullivan
mr chairman i was listening to you very
carefully
and uh
i may have misunderstood but i just want
to be sure that uh
this is being interpreted correctly as i
read this there are only two
circumstances in which
an employer would be required to
pay out the unused vacation
one would be a permanent layoff
and the second would be change of
ownership
um i thought i was hearing you talk
about a cash out when someone just
decided to leave
um
representative cahill has taken that out
of the bill
um so
it's when something happens it's beyond
the control of the employee
that the employer would be required to
pay off the unused vacation time just
want to make sure that's clear thank you
thank you
representative and then turcotte
thank you oops
thank you mr chairman and
i do appreciate the many years you and i
spent together on this committee it's
been very i often tell our members that
on the first day this is the best
committee
and i stand by that
uh regarding the uh
the cash out
uh this again
the the the proration
that happens if you say you've got two
weeks and the person quits one week into
the job
they they have no claim on two weeks
because whatever whatever you said they
could have would be pro-rated so you the
employee the employer is protected
against
that that sort of
outsized loss
and as
as
my colleague mr sullivan has
indicated this this is very very limited
very limited to only two circumstances
so
this is this is very very small
a baby step if i weigh
but i think it's the right i think it's
the right thing to do uh and i i really
i wish they could be retroactive if i
ever get this passed you know but i
can't get it retroactive because we
can't do that but maybe i'll maybe i'll
launch a gofundme for those people that
uh that were victims in this and and i
know you don't like to contribute
thank you mr chair thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman
uh i would also echo the chairman's
words to representative cahill on his
diligence and
work on this issue um
i i will have to say though that the
unfortunately the length of time put
into it and the diligence you have put
in unfortunately is not for me a reason
to pass it when we still have the basic
i guess you call it a philosophical
issue on this
i
i tend to
put bills like this in into my personal
life and
recently myself and many of our
pilots
ran into a situation where we faced
possible termination due to
you know
not getting back you know accepting the
vaccine mandate
and in that policy or in if that would
have happened
our contract allows us to build up sick
bank to a
extraordinary extraordinarily
large amount of time
had we been terminated
all of that would have gone out the
window and i can assure you it was a
stamped a substantial amount of money
but having said that
that's part of our contract
we should have the uh the gumption
while we're doing our next negotiation
to ensure that if we are terminated or
if we leave or whatever that that sick
time will be paid out
because i would agree with you in a
situation like that
if i i should get paid
but i also realize it's it's a function
of our contract and as it as it is now
we don't i mean just that's just the way
it is
we've talked about this many many many
times
the
the policies that a business and uh
employer and an employee
the policies should be laid out if they
don't that's
that's
a joint problem between the employer and
employee i as an employee if i'm going
to go get hired some place i'm going to
want to know what my benefits are what
the you know what the issues are what
the policy manual is i mean it should be
the same for the employer
um lastly i'm going to say that although
i
truly
love the input we get from mr duvet and
mr berkey and mr abbott and the others
who frequently come to our committees
here we had an individual that was not a
lobbyist um registered lobbyists come
and speak to us at this last hearing
and
uh
her name was allison something or other
i don't even remember she was a a
private business owner hr in hr
consulting
and she
did one of the best testimonies i've
ever heard here she was convincing she
was concise it was excellent she was on
point she said so many good things i
didn't write them all down but
the one note i did make on it was
she i think she finished her testimony
by saying
i see this as making law for bad
employees at the expense of the good
now again i don't remember i'm taking it
out of context here probably a little
bit but uh
you know between the lobbyists of
opposition
we've we've had this bill many many
times i think we've gone over again many
many times the issues that that are with
it i
unfortunately cannot support ought to
pass on this
seaworth
i'm sorry i apologize i already called
shows go ahead
thank you mr chair i would i would have
been fine either way but um
just two quick points
uh it is the common practice now that
uh paid time off and and sick leave but
you now many places pull them together
but
some don't um
is earned over time so there wouldn't be
especially the distinction of there's
really only two cases that this bill
would apply to anyway
um that wouldn't be
you know a bank of two weeks at the
beginning it just wouldn't be it's
that's just not the custom simply for
the reason that you stated that if i
understood you correctly
that um there wouldn't just be a big
bank of weeks
you earn in a new job unless maybe
you're a high executive maybe that works
but it typically it is always earned
like at a certain rate so many
you know one day of vacation earned for
every 30 days or you know whatever that
policy is that's very that is the common
practice in the in private business
um
that's it thank you
very much
thank you mr chairman i'm a little
concerned
i i hear
two things being said at once and they
can't both be true
um one is the assertion that this only
applies to two cases the permanent
layoff and
the transfer of business ownership
then the other thing and i just heard it
repeated
is that as a matter of fact
once
you accrue vacation time on a pro rated
basis that's cash in your pocket should
you
uh decide to leave the company at that
point so the two yes
if i'm owed two weeks for the year
and i leave after six months i don't get
the full weeks full two weeks but this
bill
says i should get one week because
that's six months worth of my two weeks
and
it clearly says that
through 24
talk about those two special cases but
outside of that paragraph in a different
section there's lines 12 through 14
which say
pay time off vacation vacation time earn
time i'm sorry i'm reading that out of
order shall be considered compensation
and therefore constitute wages do
that's not contingent upon one of these
other two
situations so
people have tried to correct the
chairman and say he misunderstood lines
12-14 and then i heard it restated that
yes as a matter of fact that means just
what it looks like it means that once
you receive accrued time
that's as good as cash in the bank uh
should you become separated
so it bothers me that we're going into a
vote where
saying the language that's before us
means two entirely different things it
obviously
is intended to mean one or the other and
it's obviously written one way or the
other and
personally i agree with everything the
chairman said about it
um
i could be corrected if i'm entirely
mistaken though thank you
representative amandaville and then
cahill
thank you um thank you mr chairman
just quickly to touch on the point um
just raised
um the way i read this uh this bill
is that uh in line 12 it says for
purposes of this section
and therefore
the definition
of
vacation time etc as wages do
is applicable to the rest of the section
and that does relate to the specific
conditions that are addressed
mr chairman you mentioned several people
having
described
intervening
between
an employer and employee is a as a as a
bad idea and i might have been one of
them you were thinking of when we were
talking about
the um
non-competes
and
uh that in the question of a non-compete
you have a
specifically typically specifically
negotiated deal between sophisticated
parties
here we're talking about something
that's usually a
non-negotiated a standard practice and
there's the question of what is
understood between the parties it's true
this just relates to two specific areas
but my concern
is that it relates to an area where
and
an employee really doesn't
understand
the the loss
that he or she will sustain
if and when one of these two things
happens it's it's not a negotiated
fourth thing it's an unperceived thing
and that's the
in inequity that this bill seeks to
address and that's why i'll support it
thank you mr chairman uh what he said
and and i will add that uh
you know i i recently studied 54 percent
of
workers leave behind vacation time and
it's either they don't use what they're
allotted and they continue employed or
they they leave
even though they're encouraged to use
the time because it's it's good for them
it's good for the company to be
refreshed and everything
but again uh this does apply to only two
these two situations where
it's i believe they're unanticipated you
know the the employer may have an idea
that he's going to sell the company
you know in a year or two but he
certainly doesn't tell the employee that
when they walk in
the employee would would not peruse the
uh the entire handbook basically you're
listening to what's the pay what's the
hours
uh how much of the health insurance do i
have to cover you're not asking about
what happens it's not an anti-nuptial
agreement
that we're considering and i know that's
very it's not very romantic if you were
saying what what happens when we break
up you know do i get to keep this and
you get to keep that
so it is again very very limited
and uh
you all you have claim to is what you've
earned
and i know that's an old
philosophical difference about whether
you earned it or it was a gift
but it's pretty clear that people earn
their vacation time and that it should
belong to them
at least under these circumstances when
they leave
thank you mr chair
senator fellas
um if you had asked me before today if
things like this ever happened that
people um
were laid off or
whatever and they thought that they had
vacation days accumulated that they were
going to get paid for and they weren't i
would i would have been astonished
i think
this bill
that that just goes on just
floors me so i to me this bill just
looks like a truth in hiring bill
so when somebody's hired
this bill requires that the employer
write down exactly the conditions that
he wants to have
related to accumulated vacation in six
days and just spell it all out it
doesn't require them to do anything
specific it doesn't require them to give
a certain number of days it doesn't
require
a
maximum number of accrued days they can
write whatever policy they want they
just need to write it down
and give it to the employee
so that they know what they're in for
so in terms of your example
you hire somebody and you tell them they
have
two days of a two weeks of vacation a
year
it should be spelled out if they earn
that right from the beginning and can
take it all in the beginning or if they
need to wait
a month and and take you know just part
of it if they accrue a day a week or a
one day a month vacation it just needs
to be spelled out it doesn't prevent
them from doing anything
they just need to spell it out so the
employee knows what they're getting into
that's my opinion from someone who has
no experience with your committee
thank you
i i appreciate you at least taking the
time to read it and make some comments
thank you representative cahill
yes i'd like to speak but only after the
gentleman with the pen has been
recognized
i apologize i don't look to my right i
apologize representative
thank you mr chairman
lines 12 through 14 are of particular
interest to business owners
we're redefining what earned time
vacation
vacation time and pay time off will be
considered compensation and therefore
therefore constitute wages due
while it looks
simple on the front
it section 44 of 275 payment of wages
the first sentence under
275.44 whenever an employer discharges
an employee the employer shall pay the
employee employees wages in full within
72 hours
if we're taking earned time vacation
time paid time off
and making it wages due
where
where is the
benefit to the employer if we're taking
away the sick time as well for being
considered as wages due maybe they have
a vacation time use it or lose a policy
but they get to bank their sick time and
if they're separated
their wages do becomes
null and void if they have a sick bank
just to make sure that we're
talking about the same thing when they
equate vacation pay with wages due
does that make sense mr chairman
thank you
one last comment from representative
thank you mr chairman and uh to uh
representative avaloni
the
sick days are not considered
wasters do they they shall not be
considered wagers do
so you would only pay and again only
under the circumstances if you
unfortunately decided to leave the
restaurant business and sold your
business and did not transfer the hours
that your employees had earned
you would be required to pay them but
not for the sick days
if you have if you use pto
instead of separating them into
different banks
then then i guess in that situation you
would
but that's a decision that you could
take it you know prior to that time
um
i wanted to correct the uh record for
our colleagues sitting in today because
the bill does not just require you to
spell it out
although there were some good business
practices up in the
first section it also requires that
under these circumstances a layoff or
transfer or sale of the business
then you would pay
the
time that the employee has earned on
their pay stub that's the main focus of
the bill
thank you mr chair
otpa
schmidt sorry representation i've been
saying schultz all day representative
smith thank you mr chairman
every big company i've ever worked for
before
has a spreadsheet and on the spreadsheet
they put down what you've earned it is
part of what they manage all their books
they just make sure
if
if section one here is followed your
vacation time your paid time off your
earned time off would be on that
spreadsheet that is part of their
responsibility to maintain their
business
i think this is a great idea especially
a section section number one where
you're asking businesses just to be
clear
it shouldn't cause any extra trouble
we're not asking anything of a business
that they shouldn't normally do but
there are some that don't and it would
be very very nice to be able to set this
uh into law
thank you
there's marshawn floor out to pass with
amendments been made seconded and we've
had um
discussion mr clark please call the role
seaworth no
avaloni
callum
no
mackie no love no
warden no dark hot
no
pro no
sullivan yes
susie yes
rudy
yes
oh i'm sorry mr schultz
cahill yes
fellows yes
schmidt yes
doomy yes
bouchard yes
yes
mandeville yes
infant time
no okay
uh 11 10.
motion fails the bill is open for
additional
uh motion
appropriate would be uh interim study or
expedient
thank you mr chairman i move uh
hb 15
14.
i t uh with amendment amended 1514 uh
warden
like to speak to your emotions sir
thank you mr chairman everything we are
we've already said i think
i'm good on that thank you
seeing no other comments are the
emotions on the floors in the street the
legislate
clerk please call the roll
seaworth yes
avalani yes
callum
yes
mackie yes love yes jordan yes
sullivan no
susie
schultz
no
cahill no
fellows no
schmidt
no
toomey
bouchard no hedgehog no
that concludes the items we have on uh
today's
executive session we have four more
bills to exec we're waiting on some
amendments
we were uh i would have liked to have
met on the 10th which is the last day we
had to
process our bills
we are not allowed to do that because
that is a house session so we'll be
meeting wednesday the 9th
i will announce the date of the time
it'll probably be uh try to do a morning
so we're done
between like 9 30 and 12
on the 9th
there's no other questions from the
chair thank you very much for your
diligence and professionalism today
we'll see you folks soon
executive session is closed
different anyways
better than anybody
really diligently yeah